- I can't stop farting recently.
It's terrible.
- I just had the most unpleasant shit,
like, five minutes ago.
Are we rolling?
- I swear it's not a
"Trash Taste" recording day
unless Garnt takes, like, a wicked shit.
Like, I know we're
about to start recording
when Garnt comes out of his, like,
shit training arc.
- It's just on schedule, you know?
- Garnt's like, "Oh, its
two PM, all right let's go."
(chill techno music plays)
- Welcome to this
episode of "Trash Taste."
I'm your host of course, your boy Connor
with Mike Wazowski here.
Nice seeing you back, Mike.
And no one else.
- I like how you grabbed the G Fuel there.
- I didn't want to hurt Mike like that.
- By the way.
- Mike!
- Mike.
I can't handle Mike that harshly.
It's great seeing you back, Mike.
And of course the boys, I guess.
- I love how we're second to Mike.
- Of course, we're all
second to Mike, Joey.
- He's the real player four.
- Mike Wazowski for all
you listeners out there.
- People are like, "Oh,
there's a guest called Mike."
- I forget sometimes that
we have audio only listeners
which shout out to you guys.
Hello.
I'm waving at you right now
even though you can't see.
- Let us know your presence.
Oh wait, you can't.
It's audio.
- So what've you boys been up to recently?
- Oh, fuck all, I guess.
I mean, this is the
first recording session
of the new year for us, right?
- Yeah, it is.
- So we just come out of our Christmas
and New Year's I guess "break."
Because it didn't really
feel like a break to me.
- Even though it's never
really a Christmas holiday
for YouTubers because I feel like,
we've talked about this many times before,
but we never, we are very
bad at taking breaks.
- If anything, it's like the
last minute grind, right,
we do at the end of the year.
- I mean, I've just been
watching a shit ton of anime
because it's the end of the year.
- I remember when I used to do that.
- This is like my one time of the year
where I actually just sit down
and just catch up to the year.
- 'Cause you don't feel bad, right?
'Cause you know that everyone's not, like,
doing anything, so it's like,
I don't feel bad for,
like, binging a few shows.
- Exactly.
- What did you binge, Garnt?
What did you watch?
- Basically most of
everything I missed in 2020.
So I watched "Jujutsu Kaisen."
- Yes, that was so good.
Have you watched that yet?
- No.
- Bro, it's so good!
- I don't watch anime.
(everyone laughs)
- Have you read the manga at least?
- No.
- It's really fuckin' good.
Like I was going into it thinking like,
are we just going to get, like,
every year there's everyone's like,
"Dude, this is the shonen.
"It's gonna replace-"
- Yeah, that's what
I've just been hearing.
Then I'm just, like, they
said that about "Dr. Stone."
They said that about a lot of
shows last couple of years.
And I'm just like, all right.
- "Jujutsu Kaisen" is where
I've actually got, like,
a chub watching it.
Like I'm actually,
(Joey laughs)
I'm actually like hyped,
like see where it goes.
- It's a show that is just,
it just knows what it's doing.
And it's obviously been, like,
influenced from previous shonen.
But my God, it's just doing everything
that it needs to do right.
- All I've heard is that
if you watch the anime
it basically does
everything the manga does.
So it just makes the manga obsolete.
- Great.
- Yeah.
I mean, that was just
"Demon Slayer," right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I want no manga.
Get rid of manga.
I'm sick and tired of these,
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
(everyone laughs)
- Why would you disrespect-
- I was like this man's done, like,
entire manga reading streams before.
- I'm about ready to
throw hands right now.
- Exactly.
- I'm tired of manga readers
constantly playing the
same damn card, right?
When is that card gonna get old?
How many times can you use the
"I've read the manga" card?
- Oh, I use it all the fuckin' time.
- How many times can you use it
before you're just an asshole?
- Oh, I just don't care.
I think a lot of manga
readers just don't care.
- So everyone just says
the "Jujutsu Kaisen" anime is exactly-
- Basically what I've heard is
that the anime does everything
the manga does but better.
- I mean, from what I understand
that's just a lot of shonen jump titles.
- Seems to be the way to go though.
- Exactly.
- I mean, "Demon Slayer" did it.
You know, "Attack on Titan" is doing it.
- Like, I don't understand
why there was even a thing of
"let's just change the story"
unless, you know, it
hadn't been adapted yet.
Hadn't been, sorry, finished yet, sorry.
Why even changed the story in my mind?
When everyone loved this thing.
So everyone's like, yeah,
everyone loves this show,
let's just change it.
- I mean, I feel like you've
started watching anime
after the period where there was, like,
so many anime adaptations
that just fucked around
with the manga and the story
that you've forgotten that
this was a legitimate, like,
selling points where we
had a manga that followed,
I mean, we had an anime
that followed the manga
through to the end.
- I can understand why they did it.
In the 90s or 80s, whatever.
- You didn't watch the 90s
shonen jump adaptations
where it's just like, "Oh
no, I liked this manga."
- I imagine the producers were just like,
"I'm sick and fuckin' tired
of these manga readers
"on their high horse.
"You know what?
"I'm a fuck them over and make something
"they can't say, oh, I know what happens."
That's probably why
because they probably, like,
brought the manga readers
to the screenings.
They were like, "Yeah, yeah?
"You know where it's going, do you?"
- No, if anything, it made
the manga readers look better
'cause then the anime
watchers would be like,
"Well, I've heard from the manga readers
"that this anime's pretty good."
And then they go and they're like,
"So what happens in the manga?
"Could you tell us?
"We're interested now finally."
- But do you find that
like the older you get,
like, the less anime that you watch
but the more manga that you read?
- Yeah, I'm in that right now.
- I feel like that's like
the path of every anime fan.
- Maybe I'm not old enough yet.
I don't know.
I haven't got there yet.
- You're, like, what, two
years younger than me?
- Yeah, exactly.
(everyone laughs)
Is 25, like, the turning point?
- To be fair it was around
your age where I was like,
"Manga's a thing."
- Really?
- Yeah.
- At 24?
- You didn't start reading
manga properly, like, until-
- No, I've been reading manga all my life.
But the thing is like
up until around, like,
a couple of years ago I would
be like very heavily, like,
I'd say like 80/20 anime/manga,
but now it's like kind of flipped around.
I'm like 80/20 manga to anime now.
- 'Cause you just realize
that reading manga is
basically watching anime
but just more optimized.
It's basically the speed run
version of watching anime.
- Basically.
- And no voice acting, no music.
What am I supposed to do?
Do this shit myself?
- The only part where it could, like,
potentially fuck up is,
like, on the author.
There's, like, no second hand to-
- It's like pure story, right?
You don't need anything else
but just the pure story.
And sometimes-
- There's only one person
to blame if it sucks.
- That's because it's like you don't know
what you're missing out because
you never think about it.
Like, you would never, I'll
keep coming back to it,
you don't know that you needed
"Giorno's Theme" in your life
until you had "Giorno's
Theme" in your life.
Like, Part Five was amazing
without "Giorno's Theme,"
but now Part Five has "Giorno's Theme,"
it's like 10 times better.
- Didn't you read the manga of Part Five
before you watched the anime?
- I did, and I think the anime is better.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, no, we can agree with that.
- Okay, we all agree with that?
I was like, wait.
I was giving it a second to sit there.
I'm like, all right I'm
waiting for the fans to turn.
- No, no, no, no.
- Of "Jojo's" by the way.
- Yeah, I haven't seen
all of Part Five yet,
but the little that I have seen is, like,
already better than the manga.
But that's not to say
that the manga is bad.
- This is a very rare case
where I feel like a legendary
manga has been adapted
into a legendary animation.
And we don't get many of those I think.
It's always one or the other.
- Because the problem is
when you have a legendary manga
everyone's expectations
is so fuckin' high.
And I think that's what's happening
with "Attack on Titan" right now.
'Cause I swear to God,
everyone is looking for
every little fuckin' nitpick
they can think of to shit on, like,
the, like, the change of studios.
Where I think MAPPA's doing a
great fuckin' job right now.
- They're fuckin' killin' it.
- And the amount of, like,
shitty takes I've seen on Twitter
when the first episode aired.
- I was streaming the
day after it came out,
and all the comments were like,
"What do you think of the 3D CGI, Connor,
"in 'Attack on Titan?'"
I was like, "I didn't
even fuckin' notice it.
"What do you mean?
"It was fine."
They're like, "It looked gross!
"What do you mean?"
I'm like, but it was like two
seconds and it looked fine.
Stop fuckin' nitpickin'.
Holy shit.
- I love all those shitty
takes where it's like,
"Oh, it's done by,
"knowing now that it's
done by MAPPA instead of,"
was it Silver Link?
No, not Silver Link.
- Studio Wit.
- It was Studio Wit.
Yeah, it's like, "Knowing
that it's done by MAPPA
"instead of Studio Wit, it
just feels different now.
"It just feels different."
- Yeah, I had this image in my head
of someone in their house, right.
They've got, like,
"Shingeki no Kyogin"
shit all over the room,
waiting with that popcorn.
They're like, "Yes!"
The moment, like, the CGI comes on, like,
"Oh, fuck this!"
(everyone laughs)
"I knew they'd fuck it up!"
- No, 'cause what I want to know is
that did they just forget
what the Colossal Titans looked like
in season two and three?
- It looked shit!
- It looked like absolute
garbage compared to the CG now.
And just because every Titan is CG now,
people, like, I don't know.
It's just bad takes.
And I feel like it's just
because it's such a
massively popular franchise
that I feel the new, like,
MAPPA are doing a great job.
And you got a great story anyway.
- That's what I love
about following, like,
those, like, massive toxic fan bases.
It's just the amount of shit
takes that come out of it is
just so entertaining.
- And people like shitting
on the opening as well.
And I'm like,
- I saw that.
- what was wrong with the opening?
- That's what people said
about the last opening!
And now everyone fuckin'
loves the last opening.
- I already get it, man.
People just get angry
every fuckin' season.
But I guess it's 'cause
the problem is, right,
is that someone has a bad take on Twitter
and then everyone fuckin' clowns on them,
so that's the only take that anyone sees
'cause everyone's fuckin'
clownin' on that guy
who's like, "The opening sucks.
"Why's it all colorful?"
- Although to be fair, the
"Attack on Titan," like,
when episode one came out,
there was a lot of shit takes.
It was just all over my timeline.
I'm like, who are these people?
- 'Cause people want brownie points, man.
And so if you're-
- Brownie points for what?
Looking like a clown?
- Well, that's the thing, right?
'Cause to these people, it's like,
people aren't gonna see if you're a clown.
But if that one time you
get a successful take
that, like, takes off.
Imagine the clout you get, Joey.
- It's like, "Yes!"
- It's like the hot, the
science behind hot takes, right?
'Cause hot takes aren't
actually hot takes.
It's like saying
unpopular opinions, right?
The unpopular opinions
that people up vote aren't
actually unpopular opinions.
You know?
It's just, like, people
say unpopular opinions
just so they can get brownie points
because it's never actually.
If it's an actual unpopular opinion,
that's the opinion that people shit on.
You know what I mean?
- That statement alone just, like,
completely negated my
"Let's Fight" series.
(everyone laughs)
'Cause that's what that show is all about.
Taking unpopular opinions.
I love that.
But like, that's why I have such trouble
with, like, making a next episode of that.
Because every time I'm like,
"Hey guys, give me your
unpopular opinions on anime."
The top replies are like,
"Boku no Piko was bad."
I'm like, "Really?
"You don't fuckin' say, mate."
- Yeah, I remember, like,
'cause voice actors do a lot
of those challenges on Twitter
that like, "Hey man, like,
"what's an unpopular
voice acting opinion."
And it was like,
"You know, I think hard
work matters the most."
And then stuff like that.
It's like, what do you mean?
That's not even an opinion.
That's genuinely good advice.
Just do the thing.
- What's unpopular about it?
- That's like the level of, like,
yeah, I don't know, man.
It's what happens.
Twitter's weird, man.
Especially when you're in
like communities on Twitter
that's, like, creative stuff.
'Cause I love watching,
artist Twitter is my favorite.
- Artist Twitter is like
watching trash TV to me.
It's like you can just grab the popcorn.
And it's like watching "90
Day Fiance" or something,
you know?
The amount of tea that
is spilled on, like,
artist Twitter, like, it's more tea
than the fuckin' Americans
threw into the water
when, like, they gained independence, man.
My fuckin' god.
- I don't know why,
but why is it almost always
written in lowercase?
It's, like, it's never proper punctuation.
It's just like, let's just make
it as lowercase as possible.
Fuckin' seven tweet thread.
And it's just like.
It's just shit that you could've summed up
into just one tweet.
- Yeah, there's a lot of funny ones.
I love it as well when it's like people,
just artists are, like,
giving advice to each other,
and they all like repeat the same stuff.
And it's always interesting sometimes
because they'll be like,
"Yeah, you should charge
people for your art."
And I'm like, is this like not known?
You should charge people for work.
Like what?
Apparently it's pretty common though.
I mean, you see the messages
on, like, For Exposure, right?
That Twitter account.
For Exposure is a Twitter
account people, like,
ask people to do things "for
exposure" which is very funny.
- Is that an unpopular
opinion you just gave?
- Doing work for free.
- That artists should get paid?
- Guys, I'm gonna do an
unpopular take right now.
- Guys, guys, guys,
don't count me for this,
but artists should get
paid for their work.
(everyone laughs)
- To be fair though, I joke on that,
but a lot of voice actors, like,
where they start out they'll
spend all their money on, like,
the new stuff and then they'll be like,
"Yeah, I'll do your commercial for free."
'Cause it's different with artists
and I think voice actors
'cause voice actors, like,
you get credits.
You need credits.
So it's like a race.
Everyone's just, like,
de-valuing themselves
'cause they're like,
"Yeah, I'll do your
Kellogg's commercial for $2
"and a Kit-Kat bar.
"Like, that's fair.
"That seems good.
"My name's on the credit though, right?"
Yeah.
- I think there is a
balance that should be taken
because there is value in clout basically.
I mean that's how we
make our money, right?
It's literally we are monetizing clout.
That is the modern day.
- We are clout chasers as an occupation.
- Go on.
- No, no, but like I get, you know,
artists should definitely be paid
and you definitely have a skill set,
but there's also building up
your personal branding as well
which you have to worry about.
- That's the problem, right,
is that so many artists starting out,
they don't see themselves
as a brand per se
because of that artist mentality.
They're not like,
"Oh no, I'm just doing it
because I like drawing.
"I don't want to make this a profession."
But then they make one piece
where it's really popular
and getting shared fuckin' everywhere.
And then suddenly they're like,
"Actually I'm a brand.
"You're stealing."
- 'Cause I've seen the
exact opposite of, like,
talented artists who just
don't know how to charge here
where you have like an artist
who has like two drawings
on their portfolio or something
and are charging, like,
ridiculous amounts of money.
And it's just like, come on.
There's a balance that
needs to be taken here.
- Yeah, my favorite is when they're like,
I've worked with some artists before.
And like great.
You know, it's all good.
You know, and it's all reasonable.
All the prices seem fair.
And then I'm like, oh, it's
for, like, commercial use
or whatever.
And they're like, "Oh,
you're like selling it?"
And then they might, like,
try and figure out like,
"Okay, you make this much money.
"It's now worth $10,000 for this piece."
And it's like, what?
What do you mean?
What?
No, okay.
- I'm pretty sure on
your website it said $20.
(everyone laughs)
- Looks at industry standard rates.
That ain't right, okay.
Well I'm not Pepsi.
I don't know.
- Which is basically the
Fiverr environment, right?
How is it like working with people.
How do you know how much you're worth?
And how to sell yourself on Fiverr?
- Because I think on Fiverr,
it's inherently people,
like, devalue themselves.
But there are people on Fiverr
who are charging like $500
for honestly what is
like really bad quality.
But then the thing is right on Fiverr,
at least I can only speak for voice actors
'cause I've hired a lot
of voice actors on Fiverr,
and like voice actors
on Fiverr there's, like,
$5 is, like, you get a very
wide variety of, like, skill.
You go all the way from headset mic.
'Cause Fiverr there's no checks.
There's no one on Fiverr being like,
"Yeah, you seem like a voice actor.
"You're good to go, champ."
It's like, "Oh, you have
something that your PC recognizes
"as an audio recording device.
"You're good to go."
- Tyler1 fuckin' headset
microphone all the way.
- I've heard people with
worse quality microphones
than Tyler1 screaming.
They're charging, like,
$20 with commercial rights
as an option.
And I'm like, what?
- What commercial?
- How do you not know
what a good microphone is,
but you know that you should be charging
for commercial rights?
Like, these two things are like, come on.
But then Fiverr does, like,
scummy things as well.
Like, Fiverr takes cuts
from, like, the tips,
and Fiverr also, like,
I don't like personally
that Fiverr charges extra
for, like, higher quality audio files.
I just think you should
just send them a WAV file.
Or high quality MP3s.
- So are people just sending MP3s-
- 128 kilobytes MP3.
- Fuckin' putting the WAV
behind jail or something.
- Yeah, they put like WAV files
behind paywalls some times.
I'm like, why?
Don't do that.
Just give me the fuckin' WAV file.
Why would you not do that?
That's, like, difference
between high and low quality.
It doesn't matter.
- I didn't know fuckin'
the voice acting industry had DLC now.
Jesus Christ!
(everyone laughs)
That's literally DLC.
- The WAV expansion.
- You want the ray tracing
voice acting pack add on.
Like, you gotta fuckin' pay $5 extra.
But it's, like, there's people on Fiverr
who, you know, charge industry rates.
And I don't think Fiverr given the,
Fiverr shouldn't be charging
industry rates in my opinion
'cause it's like not really
where you should be hiring.
Industry shouldn't be hiring on Fiverr,
and the ones that do I think
should be kind of like,
you know.
We won't get into that.
I never had that experience myself.
(everyone laughs)
But yeah, no, I mean it's difficult,
and Fiverr voice actors are,
just listen to their audio.
You'll know if they're worth it.
- I mean, it's not just Fiverr audios.
It's Fiverr-
- Everything.
- Everything, every creative
job you can think of.
The way I feel about Fiverr
is that a good testing ground
'cause you've got such a wide range.
And I feel like it would be a good place
to build up your portfolio
because from what I see, like,
it doesn't really matter
where you had your education or whatever.
What we really care about
'cause most of the time
we are the clients now.
We're buying the service.
We just care about your portfolio.
That's the thing that's
most important to me.
- Yeah, exactly.
I'm like, show me your work.
- It's a good place to build
up your portfolio as well
and also get paid.
- Yeah.
I mean, I used to recommend
to voice actors, you know,
if no one's hiring you, you
don't know where to start,
you know, don't go to
one of these websites
that costs, like, $400
a year to sign up too
'cause you're not gonna
make your money back.
- Yeah, like for example,
if we're hiring video editors,
like we can get emails about people
who are qualified for X, Y, and Z.
But at the end of the day,
we're most likely gonna pick people
who have worked on anime videos
'cause we know they
have experience working
in that fuckin' field.
- Or who, like, actually know us
and, like, watch our videos and stuff.
- Yeah, exactly.
So, that's the thing.
It's more about knowing
your target audience
and knowing what your
personal branding is.
And it's less important
about what you put on your CV
because we don't really
care about CVs that much.
- I don't give a shit
what school you went to.
Is the shit good or not?
Like, it's all there is to it.
- There's lots of video editors out there.
It's just a matter of-
- I normally go to,
like, Fiverr or somewhere
for like if I need something,
like, one off and, like, fast.
Like, I just like, because other times
it's a bit of a pain to search around.
- Have you used Fiverr other
than in your Fiverr videos?
- Yeah, I've used it.
I used it for, where did I use it?
If I need something composed.
'Cause I don't know any composers.
Like, making music.
- I go from knowing zero
composers to Kevin Penkin.
(everyone laughs)
- I can't go, "Oh, Kevin mate.
"I got this video idea.
"Could you just compose
me a track for it?"
Like, so I'll go to someone I'm like,
I'm only like make it,
like, a middy track of this
or make, like, a version of that.
It's normally very basic, like, thing
where I'm, like, "Copy this thing."
Yeah, I mean, I think I've had, like,
some emotes on my Twitch drawn there.
It was pretty decent.
Yeah, there's a lot of
Twitch stuff on there.
- I mean, there's a lot of
artists on Fiverr, right?
- Yeah, oh my god, there's so many.
- Or "artists."
- Is that where you get your Twitch stuff?
'Cause I've actually been looking to try
and, like, upgrade my Twitch presentation
because my Twitch
presentation is fuckin' shit
because I've never given the
shit about streaming before.
- Problem is on Fiverr,
it's tailored towards, like,
I think what the like
general audience of people
who are looking to get into
live streaming would want.
So it's all like very gamer looking.
You know what I mean
when I say that, right?
Like, 90% of the Fiverr
stuff for, like, Twitch,
like, Twitch overlays
all looks like something
that is an application to the FaZe Clan.
Like, it doesn't look like-
- It's like the default ones
that you get on, like, Streamlabs, right?
- Yeah, which is why I think
I ended up hiring someone
who I know that did a lot of this stuff
and who watched some of my stuff.
So they were kind of
familiar with my stuff.
- I'm thinking to update mine as well.
And I met an artist recently
who probably gonna get to hire
because yeah, at the same thing.
Like, right now I'm using,
like, a default one.
I'm just like, should probably
personalize it a little more,
make it stand out a little bit.
- How'd you guys find artists?
You just DM people on Twitter?
- I just tweet out or,
like, ask on live streams.
I'm like, "Hey guys, I need something.
"Can someone tell me like where I go?"
- A lot of them actually
I find through, like,
them doing fan art of me.
- Okay.
- Yeah, so like the person I'm
probably gonna be hiring soon
is Rocket Cat who did
like a bunch of, like,
drawings with me and Chris,
the journey across Japan stuff.
And it was really fuckin' cute.
So I asked her and I was like,
"Can you do some Twitch stuff?"
And she was like, "Okay."
So just asking around really.
- I have, like, no idea what art is worth,
so whatever they give me,
if it's not ridiculous.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, sure, fuck it.
I'll pay that.
- I'm way more comfortable
being like, "What do you want?"
You know, versus like,
"I'll give you $15."
- There's always a debate, right?
Is it you as the buyer should ask
or should the person, the client, say,
"Hey, this is what I'm worth."
Because it frustrates me when I hear like,
"What's your budget?"
And I'm like, I don't
have a fuckin' budget.
- What are you worth?
- What's your hourly rate?
You tell me.
Like, I don't know
I understand that that's in place
for people who can't maybe
afford, like, a lot of things.
But I'm like, "I don't know.
"Whatever you think it's
worth, tell me, I'll pay it."
- It's like a fuckin' standoff, right?
It's like, you're
waiting for the first one
to, like, say a number.
It's just like, how much is this worth?
Like, what's your budget?
I fuckin' hate that debate!
- I get it from the artist's perspective
because like, they're probably like,
"Oh, if I say something
that's a little too high
"then I'm afraid I might lose the client."
- Right.
That's when you can negotiate, right?
You can be like, "Ah, I think
that's a little too high."
- Yeah, but a lot of them starting off
don't know any better.
- True, true.
- I was afraid at first as well.
Like, when you know, I'd get
sponsorship opportunities
they'd be like, "What do you want for it?"
I'm like, "Ah, fuck.
"I don't know.
"How much do you have?"
- Have either you been ever
good at, like, bartering or?
- I love doing it.
- Like, I've learned to do it
just 'cause my dad was really good at it.
- I fuckin' suck at it, man.
This is why I love Japan
where everything is labeled and priced.
Because whenever I go to Thailand,
you just play this dance
around everything you buy, man.
Because it is a fuckin'
dance where you're just like,
"Oh, okay, so you're gonna charge me that?
"Well, I'm gonna, like, say a
price that's 10 times lower."
- In Australia it's, like, a
dance that you will only dance
if you decide to enter the ring.
(everyone laughs)
It's like, you can stand back
and just kind of be like,
"Oh, this is how much you want?
"All right then."
Pull your wallet out.
But then you could also be like,
"Hold on, let me roll up
my sleeves real quick.
"Let's samba, baby."
Because like my dad was so fuckin',
'cause my dad has been,
like, an IT salesman
for, like, the past 30 years.
So this man, I don't know
how the fuck he did it,
but I remember, like, when
I was in, like, high school
or something and I wanted
to buy my first guitar,
like a proper electric guitar.
And he bought me like this like
really nice Epiphone guitar
which is worth like
two grand or something.
And he looked at it and he's like,
"So this is just the guitar, right?"
And the guy's like, "Yeah."
He was like, "Can I have
a chat with you, mate?"
And he took the dude back
behind the counter into a room.
And he's like, "Hold on, son."
- Did he fuckin' beat him up?
- I don't know!
- Why'd he have to go in the back?
Why couldn't he do it at the counter?
- I don't know.
I don't know.
But he like took him to the back.
He was like, "All right, let me talk."
And then I think maybe like
10 minutes later he came out.
- It's free.
It's free.
(everyone laughs)
- Black eye.
- He came out 10 minutes later,
and he's like, "All right,
so the guitar now is 1500."
And he threw in a free amp.
And I'm like, "What did you say?
"What did you do?
"How did you do it?"
He's like, "I just talked to him, mate."
I'm like, no, no, no, no, no.
Like, if it was that easy,
then everyone would be getting deals.
It's not just a matter of,
"Oh, I just talked to him."
- Well, what did you say to him?
Everyone can talk.
- He'll never know.
- I was like, "What did you say?"
- Did he do a fuckin' Jedi mind trick?
That's technically
fuckin' talkin' isn't it?
- Did you like inception,
like, plant the seed?
And he's just like, "It's 1500 now."
- The first time I ever
saw, like, bartering happen,
I was like, my mind was blown.
I was like,
"Wait, you can go against
the price that's written?"
- You can do that?
- That's an option?
Because, like, we were on
a school trip to New York.
It was the first time
our school ever, like,
went to a different country.
- You got to go to New York for school?
- Yeah, dude.
It was chaos.
It was pure fuckin' chaos.
- What the fuck?
- How old were you?
- 16 I think.
- Oh my God.
- It was an absolute mess, bro.
- The only school trips I went to was
just, like, France at most.
That was the furthest that I've
ever gone to a school trip.
- That was, like, the bougiest one.
And for some reason, for one
year, they never did it again.
I think they realized
it was horrible mistake.
They took us to New York.
It was a fuckin' mess.
It was awful.
I mean, if I was a teacher
there I would have hated it.
I had a great time.
But yeah, I remember
it was very expensive,
but we stayed in, like,
really fuckin' sketchy motels.
I can talk about it more after the story,
but we were basically like,
I really wanted converse
'cause obviously when you're like 15, 16,
you see the shit on, like, American TV,
you're like, "Yo, Converse."
So I went to a store and
my friend was with me,
and he was in the year above me.
And I was like, "Man, I want to get these.
"But I've only got like 30 bucks left
"and they're 40 bucks."
He was like, "Oh, I'll ask
him if we can do it for 30."
He was like 17, bartering with him.
And then eventually he said,
"I'll give you for 30 if
you give me a $2 tip."
And I'm like, "Is that okay?
"Are you allowed to do that?"
I don't know if he's the owner or what,
but that's what he got it down to.
And I was so impressed.
When I went home to the
UK, I tried to do it,
but immediately all the
stores are like, "No."
(everyone laughs)
- Wait, what store was this?
- In America or the UK?
- In America.
- Was it an official store?
- I think it was like in a mall,
and it was like an
independent store maybe?
I think that's why I got away with it.
So I went to like a fuckin'
supermarket in the UK,
go to the theater-
- Go to fuckin' Tesco.
- Five pounds is a little
too much for this meal deal.
- You're selling me this
Kellogg's fuckin' Krispy Kremes
for like how much?
- I'll be like, you know,
"Three pounds is a little expensive.
"Could you do 2.50?"
- "Yeah, I'll do 2.50.
"I'll do 2.50."
- "I'll give ya 2.50."
She's like, "No, no."
I'm like, oh, okay, fuck.
And then I never tried
it again for awhile.
But I like going to
places where you can do it
because I like trying to do it.
I don't often succeed though.
- I don't know how, like,
I probably could do it
if I really wanted to,
but I'm always just so fuckin'
afraid to do it as well.
- You're like um.
- 'Cause with that kind of stuff,
if you're not coming in with confidence,
you're basically fucked.
There's no way you're gonna win it.
- You need to come in with,
like, a winning mentality.
- You gotta come up in with,
like, the biggest dick energy.
- Like, I can do it.
It just takes so much fuckin' energy.
But whenever you're in a
place in, like, Thailand,
that's like 90% of the stores you go to,
and you just want a store
where you pay the price
that they originally ask for
and just not have to like do
this mini game every time.
- I remember I watched like the,
I think I mentioned him
on the YouTube rep series.
He does videos about Prague.
He covers, like, taxi scams.
And I was in Prague, and I had a taxi,
and I was like this is
like in the simulations.
This is exactly what he spoke about
'cause they were trying to charge me
what he said was being overcharged.
I remember I was with my mate in a taxi.
I'm like, "No, no I've
seen the YouTube video.
"I've got this."
I was like, "I'm not paying that.
"That's too much."
And eventually we got
it, like, half the price.
It was supposed to be, like, 50 euros
for like the equivalent in Czech money
for, like, it was supposed
to be, like, half that.
It was like only like a 20
minute, like 15 minute journey.
I was like, "No, I've
seen the simulations.
"I know this is right."
And there's YouTube channels of dudes
who go around India, like, bartering.
- Oh yeah.
- I can imagine bartering in
India is just like next level.
That's like expert mode, man.
- It's literally,
it looks like a reality TV
show with every purchase.
The guy's like, "I'm walking away.
"I'm going, I'm not getting in your taxi."
And then they're like following him.
- "No, no, no, please, please!"
- "Please, please, sir!"
- This episode is sponsored
by Princess Connect Re:Dive,
one of the most successful
gacha games in Japan since
its release which is
now available worldwide
on iOS and Android.
- While Joey tells you all
about Princess Connect Re:Dive,
me and Garnt are going
to be eating onigiri,
and we're gonna see who can eat the most
before Joey finishes his ad read.
Although these are literally
just blocks of carbs.
So set your expectations low.
- So I'm gonna be reading this as slowly
as humanly possible.
- No, no, no, no.
- Why did we agree to this?
- All right, Joey, you
may proceed to tell us
about today's sponsor.
As fast as you can please.
- Please go.
- Let's introduce.
I'm just kidding.
Let's introduce you to the
game Princess Connect Re:Dive,
one of the hottest and successful
gacha games from Japan.
Princess Connect Re:Dive
was developed by Cygames,
the developer of
Shadowverse, Dragalia Lost,
and Granblue Fantasy.
Shut up, Garnt.
I'm reading a script.
So you can expect
that this game is amazing.
- There's no flavor.
- [Joey] This all-inclusive
anime RPG is full
of beautifully animated cutscenes,
special abilities, and characters.
Furthermore, it has
such an incredible deep
and original story
that there's even an
anime based off the game,
which was released last year in 2020
with season two on the way,
so look forward to that.
There are over 50 heroines and counting.
Strengthen and ascend them to
reach their full potential.
- There's no flavor!
- [Joey] Every character and guild has
their own unique story
to unlock and is voiced
by the most popular voice
actresses in the industry.
Build your own personal guild house,
fight for the top ranks
of multiple PVP modes,
battle with your clan, conquer dungeons,
and plenty more with plenty of events,
cross brand collaborations,
and new content to keep players engaged.
And you know what?
Just like Garnt and Connor,
there'll be plenty of rice balls
during your journey as well.
We're not just doing this
because it's like a weird thing-
- What the fuck is this script?
- I'm not even hungry.
- So make sure to click the links down
in the description below to
get the game for yourself.
And thank you to Princess
Connect Re:Dive once again
for sponsoring this video.
Time!
- I won!
- Hey, Garnt won!
- It tastes so boring.
- [Meilyne] Show your plates.
- Wait, what?
You had two?
No, you didn't.
Cheating.
There's some foul play going on here.
- Thank you to Princess Connect Re:Dive
for sponsoring this episode.
Back to the video.
- Get good, Conner.
Get good.
- But yeah, back to my
school trip to America.
It was my first time
ever going to America.
- Right.
- And I remember there was two things.
I was really excited for going to America.
What do you think they were?
- In-N-Out?
- No, I didn't go there.
I only went to New York.
- Oh, you only went to New York.
- The food?
- I wanted two things from
what I'd seen from media.
I wanted Twinkies,
and I wanted Mountain Dew.
- Wait, do they not
have Mountain Dew in UK?
- They do, but it's not, like,
it's the stuff without,
like, the green stuff in it
because that stuff's illegal in the UK.
- Is it?
- Our Mountain Dew just
tastes like Sprite.
- What?
- We have it, but it's not that popular
and it doesn't taste
like Mountain Dew at all.
- Really?
- It's not proper Mountain Dew.
- What the fuck is in Mountain Dew
that makes it illegal in the UK?
- The stuff that makes it super green.
- Really?
- Like, 'cause I'm pretty sure, like,
all the sodas in the UK
you're not allowed to
use corn syrup either.
- Oh.
- So, like Coke and soda
in America tastes different
from, like, sodas in the UK.
- Right, right.
- Ours does have less sugar in it as well.
- It has, like, a little less
sugar, and you can taste it.
You can definitely taste the difference.
- Oh yeah.
The first time I had,
like, proper Mountain Dew,
or I guess now I know is
proper Mountain Dew in America,
was like-
- Australia might have
different, it might not.
But Twinkies are shit.
Twinkies tastes like ass.
- Why did you think it was good?
- Because in all the TV shows
they made Twinkies look amazing!
- Did they?
- Yeah.
- From what TV show?
- Maybe like "Zombie Land"
or something actually
because he's obsessed with
them in "Zombie Land."
- Oh yeah.
- Then I also learned that they, like,
can survive nukes or something.
I don't think that's true at all.
But in "Family Guy-"
- It's like survival food.
- I wonder how much Twinkies
paid "Zombie Land" like
to fuckin' promote.
- That was fantastic advertising.
- That was like five head
advertising right there.
- I went there as a teenager,
and I fuckin' wanted Twinkies.
- The shitty spongy thing
that you put into your mouth,
survival food.
During an apocalypse.
- My God, so like I'm prone
to getting like nosebleeds
as well until I got my nose cauterized
which is like, when you
get like fuckin' burn it.
So, if it got like even remotely
hot I would get nosebleeds.
So when I went to America,
it was just too hot
'cause it was in the summer
and I just every day I had nose bleeds.
- How hot does it get in
New York in the summer?
- It's pretty damn hot.
- Pretty humid.
- Yeah, I remember I went to
New York once in the summer,
and it was like pretty hot and humid.
Like, in the 30s.
- I don't know why I thought
because it's so cold in the winter
I would assume it got, like,
quite cool in the summer.
- It was great though
'cause any of the like
really boring places,
I would just be like, come on.
And then I'd get to go get
ice cream or something.
The staff would go take me out.
'Cause we were like going
through like one museum
that was really fucking boring.
I can't remember what it was as a kid.
- Oh, it's the big museum
in New York, right?
- No, the Smithsonian was pretty cool
'cause that has, like,
loads of exhibits and stuff.
There was some other
museum they took us to
which was like, maybe it was, like,
some CIA thing that was, like, just books.
And I was like, I have
no interest in this.
- I have no interest.
Pow!
- They just like, let us go
around Times Square on our own.
- Really?
That could have gone horrendously wrong.
- Yeah, that sounds really dangerous.
Like, Times Square is like-
- I wouldn't let my 16 year old kid.
- I don't even feel safe
during the day in Times Square
let alone at a night.
- I don't feel safe as an adult there
let alone like a 16 year old kid.
- And I remember (laughs)
It's just so funny.
One of the kids came back
and he had a bunch of CDs.
And we were like, "Why do you have CDs?"
He's like, "Oh, well the
guys kept coming up to me
"and telling me if I
wanted to hear them spit.
"So I kept having to buy
them for five dollars."
And I was like, you know, the
dudes come up to you like,
"Yo, here's mix tape."
He was paying every time for
everyone that came up to him.
(everyone laughs)
- So he just has all of
these, like, shitty mix tapes.
- I can't remember what I did.
I think I just went around all the stores,
just looked at it and be like,
"Wow, it's just so strange."
Would go in like M&M World and be like,
"Wow, I can't afford any of it."
(everyone laughs)
Because it would be like
$10 for a pack of M&Ms.
I'm like, "Wow, I'm really broke, huh?
"My parents really didn't
give me enough money."
- Can't even afford M&Ms.
- No.
I remember as well, our
hotel, they put us in, like,
I think it's like the sun
inn, what is that called?
It's like the Comfort Inn or something?
Is that what it's called?
The chain?
- It's the sun...
- It's got like a sun logo.
I think it's called Comfort Inn.
And I remember we were all baffled
because the only thing they had
for breakfast was like burgers
that could be microwaved.
And it was disgusting.
We were all like, "Yeah, American food!"
We ate it, and we were
like, "Oh, American food."
- It's like some White Castle shit.
- Yeah, it was gross.
I remember as well that we
had to get the bus everywhere.
And it was just the worst
'cause they tried to fit,
like they used public
buses, like private coaches.
- The more you're talking
the more I'm realizing
who decided to go on a
school trip to New York?
- I think it must have been one teacher
that really fuckin' wanted to go.
- It makes sense that they
didn't do it the year after.
- So, we would go on,
like, the public buses.
Like, the whole, like,
40 kids would go on a normal public bus.
It was already full.
- That sounds terrifying.
- Yeah, and then all the dudes
were like topless on the bus.
And we were like, "Oh God,
oh God, I'm in danger."
And then when the teachers
would all go to bed,
all the fuckin' kids
just went out at night.
(everyone laughs)
And we were in 'cause we were obviously,
we were like not a rich school at all.
So we were in, like, the really
sketchy part of New York.
- But you're rich enough
to go to New York though.
- Not really.
I remember the whole trip
for like four or five days
with flights and five
hotels was, like, 800 pounds
and everything was taken for.
- I guess that has to
compensate for the flights.
- Very budget, very budget.
So the hotels we stayed in
were, like, not good at all.
- Were they, like, in the ghetto?
- Bro, we were hella.
Imagine it, you've got like 40 just, like,
white school kids that have
no idea what's going on.
Then they break out at
night in like a ghetto.
It's like, oh God.
- Were you guys in, like,
Harlem or something?
- I can't remember where we
were, but we were very far away.
It was like a 40 minute
bus journey into town.
- Oh, Jesus, that could've
been anywhere sketch.
- Yeah, I think we were-
- Like Queens maybe.
- I think we might've been
around somewhere like that.
It was definitely, I remember that,
I remember having these,
because you would see on the
movies that New York was like,
yeah man, it's bustling, it's great.
I was like,
"Why is where we're staying
everything is boarded up
"and dirty?
"What's up with that?"
- Because the hustling
bustling is like two blocks
in Manhattan.
- I distinctly remember I
really didn't like New York,
and I liked DC because when we went to DC,
it was really nice.
And I remember that
'cause I was just scared
when we were in New York.
- That was my first impression
going to New York as well.
I also went when, I was a bit older.
So I was like 22 or something like that.
- I feel like when you're 16 and 22,
the way you see the world
is completely different.
- I don't know.
I still had this, like, you know,
the American film image of New York.
And I remember my first time going there,
I remember thinking,
"Man, there's a lot of street
corners that I've never seen
"in any films that look
pretty fuckin' dodgy."
- This is where, like,
Spider-Man's parents got killed.
- That's the thing.
When I went to New York
like four or five years ago,
like, it was really good
as long as your neck was
like above, like, landscape.
Like, "Wow, these buildings
look really good."
And the moment you look
down and just like,
"Oh, that's a lot of trash."
- That was my first impression.
There is a lot of trash
that just has never appeared on any films.
- Like, there is mountain
of trash on this corner
that is like reaching,
like, traffic lights.
- Like, my God, going to
Chinatown for the first time,
it don't hit different.
It smell differently, man.
(everyone laughs)
- This is episode 33
where we clown on America.
- Actually I remember on stream yesterday,
I had a person coming and being like,
"Why do you guys hate America?"
- We don't hate America.
I love how absurd America is.
- The way I talk about Americans is
like the way I like to shit on my cousins.
You know what I mean?
It's like the distant cousin
that I just like to talk shit about.
- We don't hate on America.
We just like making fun of America.
There's a big difference.
- You know, Europe's boring.
There's nothing weird about it.
America is weird to a T,
and that's why I love it.
- Yeah, no, it comes from a place of love.
You know what I mean?
This is how us Brits show like,
we, you know, we talk
shit to our like mates.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's how I see it.
- Yeah, they're like,
"Innit, oh, your teeth are shit.
"Go drink and some tea."
And they're like, "Wait, why
are you making fun of America?"
- Call your mates "cunts,"
and ya call cunts "mate."
That's how it works.
- True, true.
Would you ever live in America?
Have I asked this before on the podcast?
- I don't think you've
asked me on the podcast.
- I think I've asked you personally.
- Yeah.
- Can't remember what your answer was.
That's why I'm asking again.
- I mean like, I've given it-
- You're dating, because
you're both with Americans.
(Garnt laughs)
- Yeah, we hate Americans.
We hate America, we hate
Americans so much so
that are significant others are
from that country.
- Are Americans.
- I don't know the way Sydney talks to me
about food sometimes
with, like, a nostalgia.
I'm like, disgusting.
Gosh.
- I've considered living in
America for maybe like a year
just to like give it a go.
- Like, it's an asylum.
I would go there to visit, you know?
- Like, for real I don't hate visiting.
Like, I love visiting
America, but I don't, like,
I don't know.
Just difference in
personality at least with me
and, like, way of living is, like,
it's very different to
what I'm used to open.
- I love how open everyone is.
- I do love how open everything is,
open everyone is.
I feel like the biggest thing
I would have to get to is,
like, I like feeling safe.
(everyone laughs)
- No, legit, legit.
The only thing stopping me
from living in America is
the fact that even during
the day I don't feel safe.
- Yeah, like it's so weird for me
where you can be in some
of the most famous places
in the world in America, and
you just can't walk anywhere.
I like walking to places,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah, Japan is all
about walking everywhere.
- I feel like I have to
recalibrate my brain in order
to travel to places in America
because I forget that you
have to just drive everywhere
and just walking isn't normalized
because, you know, it's just not safe.
- Even when you're in like
the middle of LA, right?
Like, you'd be like,
"Oh, you know, I'll just
like go to the Starbucks
"that's just around the corner."
You know, it's like just going
to the next town in an RPG.
And yet on the street corner,
there's a level 100 crackhead
standing there being like,
"You gonna come passed me?"
- When I was in San Francisco, man,
just walking back to my
hotel at 2:00 AM felt
like a Cyberpunk mission, dude.
- Yeah, honestly.
It's scary there!
- The fuckin' music
was playing in my ears.
- The fact that you said
you walked back at 2:00 AM
just like already scares me.
- Okay, I legit have never been scared
just walking somewhere.
I was right in the middle
of like the financial
district in San Francisco.
I was like, "Fuck."
I think I've mentioned it
before on the podcast a while.
But yeah, that was fuckin' scary.
Fuck, I'm scared.
I'm scared thinking about it.
- That's the only thing that's stopping me
from living in America.
- Also everyone I know from San Francisco
has had their car broken into.
- Yeah, I've heard so many
weird stories about, like,
some of the stories that Meilyne says
'cause Meilyne is from San Fran
where it's one of it's, like,
it's so counter-intuitive for
me where this is the place
where it's got like one of, like,
the highest cost of living in the world.
- Pay like a million dollars
a year to live there.
- Like, a millionaire is
considered like poor there.
You know what I mean?
That's kind of the place
we're talking about,
yet it's a place where the
cost of living is so high,
yet it seems like you still need to worry
about some of the stuff
where I feel like if I'm
earning a million dollars,
I wouldn't need to worry about it.
Like, why would I need to worry?
Like why would I need to pay this much
and worry about living in a neighborhood
where my car could get broken into?
Yet, it feels like everyone
who I've met from San Fran
has had something stolen
or something robbed.
- They talk about that
as if they got, like,
a parking ticket.
You know, it's like, "Ah, shit.
"Got it again.
"Oh, well."
- Yeah, when Meilyne was talking
about how she has to have
like one headphone in
just in case of someone
behind her to, like,
take her purse or something,
I'm like, "What the fuck?"
- Like, why would you, how
do you feel safe living
in a city like that or a country
like that for that matter?
- This is why I'm convinced
the Cyber truck's being made.
It's purely so it can withstand criminals
in San Francisco breaking in.
Everyone's gonna be in, like,
fuckin', like, armored
trucks in San Francisco.
But they'll still find
a way to break into it.
- But that's the thing,
the only places I feel
safe in America are, like,
the super tourist heavy places right.
So like the piers in San Francisco,
or like, you know, fuckin' Vegas strip.
- Yeah, UK's somewhere
in the middle I think.
Like, you can't really,
like, leave your laptop
on the dashboard really?
- I would argue though,
like, other than Japan,
there's not a lot of countries
where you can do that.
- No, no, not really.
But like in the UK, I'd leave, like,
my headphones on the chair.
I don't really mind risking that.
I'm like, whatever.
- No, I wouldn't even do that.
- Well, it depends where you are.
London?
No.
Like, Wales?
Yeah, it's whatever.
- Well, yeah, because
that's countryside, right?
- What are they gonna do?
Run away with the sheep?
- Get on the sheep.
"All right, go, go, go!"
(everyone laughs)
- I mean, yeah, I don't know.
It's weird.
I've always said this
I've always wanted to live
in America for a year.
- I would like to live in America for-
- I wouldn't mind trying it out.
- I think if I moved from Japan,
I think I would like to try and get-
- I'm still like because
me and Sydney want to move
to America for a bit
because, like, her family's there
and, you know, she wants
to be close to her family
for a while.
It's just finding the perfect place
that I would actually want
to live in for a while.
'Cause I don't know where I
could see myself settling down
in America.
- Because like, you know,
for YouTubers it's, like,
the number one spot is always
LA, but fuck living in LA.
Sorry if you're from LA.
- No, it's not about LA.
It's about LA YouTubers, man.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- LA YouTubers are different beasts, man.
- They are a different breed.
- I feel like there's literally
just two scenes on YouTube,
YouTube and LA YouTube.
It's totally different.
Like, and you know, when
someone's living in LA I swear
'cause when you talk to them, you're like,
"Bro, you're just, like,
in another reality."
- "You sound brainwashed."
- But I get it because
like when you're there,
like, you feel it.
You feel like you're in a
different place when you're in LA,
and you feel like everything you do
somehow has a bigger weight to it I think.
I think that's what they think.
- Everything's like
brand, fuckin' marketing.
- We were talking about
clout chasing before,
LA's like the epicenter
of clout chasing I feel.
Like, everyone's out to get some clout.
- Yeah, I feel dirty when I'm there.
When I'm talking to people.
- I'm just, like, I'm just
trying to get Starbucks, bro.
Like, why are we talking
about how many subs you have?
Like, I don't care.
- But did you see, like, that
Dunkey video where he, like,
did a commentary over-
- The 100 Thieves.
- The 100 Thieves one.
I'm just like-
- Oh, the house!
- Yeah, the 100 Thieves house.
- 100 Thieves is an E-sports
organization made by Nadeshot
who used to be a YouTuber.
But yeah, he started one,
so he has his own little,
you want to go tell the rest of it?
- Yeah, so he basically
commentates over, like,
this house tour.
And it is like, the way
Dunkey commentates it is
basically like you're going
into a different fuckin' world
'cause what was like the room?
Like the fuckin'
- Tortino's.
- Tortino Fortnite
training room or something.
I'm just like, this sounds like a,
you say out of context
and this sounds like
a dystopian nightmare.
- Every room has a
sponsor in the building.
So when you mention I'm in this room,
you have to say like, I'm in
the Monster Energy gaming room.
(Joey laughs)
I want that for Trash Tastes.
- This is our Del Taco's toilet.
(everyone laughs)
- I'm in the Tenga recording room.
- Dude, I'll fuckin'
have Tenga sponsor us.
- Tenga coffee room.
- Yes, yes, yes.
- We should probably
explain what a Tenga is
to the audience I guess.
- Oh yeah 'cause YouTube
just recently got one, right?
- We got a joke gift from a friend of ours
who gave us a Tenga which is just-
- A Tenga is just a,
is a branded fleshlight.
- A fleshlight.
No, a Japanese fleshlight.
- It's a high class fleshlight.
- Fleshlights when I see them,
they make me look uncomfortable.
Like, sorry, when I see
them I feel uncomfortable.
Like, I see it and I'm like,
why does it look like that?
Why's it look like Donkey Kong's lips?
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
It's fuckin' disgusting.
What is that?
It's so gross.
- I've never heard anyone refer to a Tenga
as Donkey Kong's lips.
- No, the stereotypical
fleshlight you see,
why would anyone want to
stick their dick in that?
It looks disgusting.
- Yeah, that's true.
- How horny you gotta be to do that?
You know, I don't wanna know.
- Because the thing is no
one's using like a fleshlight
and actually looking at it to be like,
"Oh yeah, I'm like basically
fucking a pussy a now."
You know what I mean?
(everyone laughs)
Like, nobody cares what it looks like.
- That's so gross.
- I don't know how Tenga
managed to make it look normal.
- No they make it look like a-
- Like an ornament.
- Yeah, like a sleek thing.
If you come to Japan, go check it out.
They're in, like, Don Quijote.
Like, in a lot of stores.
- Yeah, so there's like
different types of Tenga.
I remember the first
time I heard of it was
just the Tenga eggs, which-
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- How do those work?
- I've never seen that.
- You've never seen them?
It's, like, you can get like a half dozen
or like a dozen of them.
It's in an actual, like, egg carton.
- So yeah, they sell actual egg cartons,
and there's these Tenga eggs,
which are actually like, I've never-
- Where do you put your dick in there?
- So, how does it work?
- So you have to like crack it open
and then it kind of stretches out.
So, it's basically just like-
- So wait, you literally just
crack it open on the side and-
- You kinda just fuckin' do
this and it cracks on the side.
And then basically, like,
the fleshlight part is
kind of, like, squashed in.
So you like stretch it out,
and then you kind of just wrap it up.
Don't ask me how I know that.
(everyone laughs)
- You know what's one thing
I've never understood?
People who jack off in their socks.
What's up with that?
- Yeah.
- I don't know anyone who
jacks off in their socks.
- I hear it all the time.
- I thought that was just an urban legend.
- There was someone in
my university who did it.
He would jack off into,
he had socks specifically for jacking off.
- Why would you give your
dick carpet burn like that?
Like, how is that fuckin'
comfortable at all?
- For some reason,
the thought of using
tissue is too much effort.
- It's like rubbing your
bare dick on the carpet.
It just sounds like it hurts.
- Is that how furries happened?
(everyone laughs)
- That's the first step of yiffy.
That's how you yiff.
- You get a taste for the
fur, you can't go back.
- But you hear it all the time, right?
It's like the whole, like,
crusty socks kind of thing.
I'm just like, (laughs)
that's a funny fictional thing
that never happens.
- So the guy in my one, he would use them,
like he would use his
dirty socks that he could,
you know, when you go to
bed, you take off your socks.
So, he would just throw them in his room.
Then when he was going to
do it, he would grab one.
And then he was like,
"Well, it doesn't matter.
"I'm gonna wash it anyway."
I'm like, "So wait, you're telling me,
"Let me get this straight.
"You might've played rugby,
you might've gone running.
"You would use that sock and then-"
- Dude, he literally gave
himself his own foot job.
(everyone laughs)
He gave himself a self
foot job, basically.
- But a sweaty stinky foot job.
- I'm so sorry to the listeners
who are grossed out by this.
But yeah, I just couldn't believe it.
And I've asked people
like, "Do you do this?
"Is this is a thing?
"Do you know anyone?"
I know people who know people who do it.
And I'm like, "Why are
you friends with them?
"What's wrong with you?"
- Yeah, but what if they're doing like a,
"Oh yeah, a friend of a friend of mine,"
but it's actually them?
- I've heard people who
have found out, like,
the sister found their brother doing it.
I've heard that.
- Oh, that's the worst.
- That's gross.
Imagine walking in your brother's,
you see his, like, socks.
"Why are they crusty?"
(everyone laughs)
- Oh my God.
- I just don't understand how they,
'cause I've heard of people
as well using the same sock
more than once without cleaning it.
- What?
- Do they want to get like a fuckin' UTI?
- It's just like the speed
run any percent to, like,
a sexual transmitted disease.
Like, I don't understand.
- Chlamydia any percent.
- This is like Victorian
era syphilis simulator.
Like, what is this?
- At which point was the
tissue just too, like,
complicated to figure out?
- Get a box.
They're not hard to put on any surface.
They're flat, you know, just.
- Or if you can't even do that,
just roll of toilet paper, you know,
like that'll also suffice.
- I just don't understand.
- I mean like, dude, aside from, like,
fuckin' apparently wanking into socks
which is what we're talking about.
Do you actually know
anyone who owns, like,
a fuckin' pocket pussy?
- Like, a non Tenga?
- Yeah, like a non Tenga.
- I feel like people don't admit it.
I feel like it's probably
way more than I realize.
- I don't know anyone who's, like I-
- 'Cause they're not telling you, Garnt.
They're not telling you.
- Is it just a thing that guys
just don't tell each other?
Or is it just a thing
that guys just don't buy?
I don't know.
- I think there's a
certain shame in admitting
that you cum into a plastic toy.
- Yeah.
I feel as well, like maybe
we're just hanging out
with, like, not those kinds of people.
You know what I mean?
- [Garnt] I think it's also because like-
- No, I'm kidding.
(everyone laughs)
- Like you said, they look fuckin' ugly
and look fuckin' weird.
Like, there's no way that
your mom opens a drawer
and sees like an owner
hole or pocket pussy.
How do you explain that shit away?
- Like, to me in my mind,
it has to be like,
there's two graphs, right?
There's effort to clean it
and enjoyment I get out of it.
And it-
- Are you like midmaxing
pocket pussies right now?
- Because the problem is, right,
is that I don't want to clean it.
I don't want anything to
do with it when I'm done.
I want it to be done and dusted.
You get it in a tissue,
you throw that shit away.
It's gone.
It's out of my mind.
Like, worst case scenario
if I'm really desperate
for lube for some reason,
I'm sure I can just lube up my hand.
But I don't want to make a mess.
That is like my priority here.
I just want to get this over with.
I'm not trying to have, like,
I'm not lighting candles,
you know, scenting the air.
Like, I don't give a fuck.
I'm just trying to get it done.
- Turn on the mood lights.
(everyone laughs)
- Like, I don't understand, like,
it's that enjoyable to them
that they're willing to
go then to the kitchen,
have this shameful thing and just like,
"All right, I'm gonna clean out my jizz."
Like, I don't want to touch that.
I don't want to fuckin'
do anything with it.
I get disgusted when I get
a little bit on my hand.
I'm like, "Oh no, that won't do at all.
"Get that off."
- It's just some people
just don't care, man.
- It's just weird for me because, like,
it seems like it's, you know,
socially acceptable for
girls to have, like,
whatever sex toy they want, right?
And I mean, they sell it
on high street stores.
Like in England we have Ann Summers
where you can go in there and-
- I mean, I get it.
For a guy it's like you can
do it in, like, two seconds.
Get it done, done and dusted
if you really need to.
For a girl I guess it takes longer.
It's a bit harder.
- For the girl, you
actually have to, like,
light the candles and
turn on the mood lights.
- Yeah, but I also imagine, like,
fingering yourself is,
I wouldn't know.
(Connor laughs)
It's probably a little more difficult.
I don't know, man.
- I wouldn't know that
the thumb is way harder
than the pinky, no.
(everyone laughs)
- I wouldn't know.
- This is getting way too
graphic for this podcast.
- Cut that, cut that.
- Have you though?
- What?
Fingered myself?
- Yeah.
- No.
What?
- Yeah, me neither.
- Okay Joey, what the fuck?
I'm guessing we're cutting this.
- No.
- What the fuck?
Where the fuck did that come from?
- Are you admitting that
you fingered yourself?
- No!
- Do you have something
you wanna tell us, Joey?
- I said no!
- Something you wanna admit, bro?
- That's like the have you ever?
- We're all homies here.
- No, no, no, no.
- My homies don't like fingering.
- Joey's like, "My stool broke one time.
"I've never been the same."
(Joey laughs)
- But yeah, I guess like coming to Japan
I am impressed by the
fuckin' variety of sex toys.
I mean, I see it way more often
because you know I'm fuckin' dating Sydney
and it's her fuckin' job
to review these different types of things.
But man, they are so imaginative and I-
- I unironically love going to just, like,
there's one in Akihabara
that I always go to called Love
Merci, I think it's called.
And it's like under the bridge,
and it's like a four-story
fuckin' sex shop.
- Oh yeah.
And that's right in the
middle of Akihabara, isn't it?
- Right in front of the station!
- It doesn't look like a adult store.
- And like the fourth floor,
like the top floor is, like,
no females allowed
'cause, like, that's where
all like the guy toys
and, like, the fucked up porn is.
And I was like, "How bad could it be?"
So I went up there, and I was like,
"Yeah, I'm allowed on
this floor technically
"under the rules of the store,
"but I don't want to be on this floor."
- It feels illegal just being around that.
(Joey laughs)
- I feel like I'm committing
a felony just being here.
- When you get up higher and
then you see the sex dolls.
- They creep me the fuck out, bro.
- And they're fucking expensive too.
- Like, 10 grand, right?
- Yeah.
Like, the good quality ones.
I'm like, what's the difference?
- The thought of having
to clean out, like,
a fake person is so disgusting.
- What is the maintenance cost
on these fuckin' dolls, man?
Like, they must be more
expensive to fuckin' maintain
than just going out to a soapland.
- But that's what I'm thinking.
These things are so expensive.
You're better off going
to, like, a soapland,
you know, 10, 20 times.
- I guess there's the shame, right?
I get it.
It's a bit different, but I get it.
I get it though.
Like financially it makes sense.
- The shame?
- The shame of having
to go to a prostitute
or something basically.
- I think I'd rather do that
than fuckin' buy a doll.
- The shame of having
someone look back at you.
(everyone laughs)
As opposed to like
looking at lifeless eyes.
They can't judge.
- If other people want to
fuckin' do it, that's fine.
I don't care.
I can't do that, man.
The shame would be too much for me.
- I had a mate who, like,
couldn't go to any strip clubs
'cause he was just like, yeah,
"Going to a strip club is
just like looking at porn
"that can look back at you, man."
- I've never been to a strip club,
and they always just seem
weird, the idea of it.
And it's sad because
everyone always tells me
the food is, like, normally
the best part of it.
- What?
- I would not order food at a strip club.
- Me and the boys go to a strip club
just to have, like, a
five-course delicate meal, man.
- Why not?
I would!
- It's like your friend is like,
"Yo, I know this fuckin' great strip club.
"Steaks are fuckin' bomb here."
- Someone said, like, I
can't remember who it was,
someone in America.
They're like, "Yeah, dude,
the wings were bomb."
(everyone laughs)
I'm like, yeah, in my mind,
if any food would be good in a strip club
for some reason it would be wings
- At that point, does that
mean you've just gone to
too many strip clubs where you go there,
and they're just like naked girls dancing,
you're like, "No, no, no, no.
"Give me the wings.
"I want the wings."
- I would pay for a YouTube series
where someone is, like,
very loudly in, like,
a music blaring, he's like
reviewing a strip club
and the wings.
I would pay good money for that.
- A review.
- Like, a report of the
week in a strip club.
Like, reviewing the wings.
He's like, "Can you turn the
music down a little bit?"
I fear for what I don't know.
I don't want to use any of these sex toys
because I don't want to start liking them.
'Cause I feel like I'm
just gonna just get more
and more extravagant with it
until the maintenance
costs are through the roof.
I'm happy with where I'm at right now.
Just beating my meat and
just getting it done.
- With my own trusty hand.
- It does the job.
I don't need more than that.
- That's why I'm afraid of, like,
trying something like VR porn.
You know what I mean?
Where it's just, like, this is going-
- What if I like it?
- This is going an extra mile here.
Exactly.
Like, what if I like it?
What if I experienced
something new from this?
I don't know.
I don't want, I'm in a happy relationship.
- You recently bought a VR headset, right?
- I bought it to play fuckin' games!
I want to play Half-life Index, okay?
- There is no way there is
a part of you that is, like,
I gotta try this out.
There is no way there isn't a part of you.
- Of course there is.
- So?
- I just don't like the idea
of cumming with a headset on.
There's something about
that that feels wrong.
Like, I'm wearing a big headset
with these controllers and shit.
Are you kidding me?
- I can imagine just, like, you climax
and, like, the post nut shame
must be on another level.
- Take the headset off.
- It's like, "Oh, God!"
- You've got the
controllers and you're like,
"Oh, this is where my
life has led me now."
- You're just like, "(sighs) Beat Saber."
(everyone laughs)
Again, like, I feel like-
- You just did a video
on this, didn't you?
Where you went to illusion.
- Yeah, I went to illusion
and played the VR porn games
that they made.
It's fuckin' weird.
Like, I dunno.
I did like a "safe for work" one.
It was barely safe for work.
- If you were in the privacy of your home,
could you nut to it?
(Joey sighs)
- If I tried really hard, maybe.
- What do you mean if you
could try really hard?
- If I was given like 30
minutes to myself, like maybe.
- I'm sure I could
manage to cum to anything
if I had 30 minutes.
- That's what I'm saying.
- It's not the optimal thing I would use
because it's like, I dunno.
There's a part,
it was really fun to do because
it's just so ridiculous.
But there's just so much
about it that's just so jank
where you're just like,
"Oh, okay, I'm supposed to
be lying down in this thing
"but I'm also standing up.
"And if I look down, I just
look into the guy's neck."
It's just a bit weird.
- That's the thing about VR porn, right?
I mean, you have to be
dedicated to this wank session.
You know what I mean?
There are so many steps you are putting on
just to jack off, you know?
- What if the sensors get, like,
they stop working midwank?
What am I supposed to do?
Just finish?
- I guess so, I guess so.
- It's not exactly a casual wank, is it?
You know what I mean?
- It's a ranked competitive wank.
- It's a fuckin' side quest.
- I guess the thought I had was
I've watched the least
amount of anime this year,
and I feel like a lot of people-
- You mean last year?
- Oh, sorry, fuck off.
Last year.
- Hey.
- I've watched the least
amount of anime last year.
And I feel like a lot of people
in the anime fandom have.
And I feel like the
community now is evolving
from just being like,
there's a difference between
now being an anime fan
and a weeb, and we
touched on this earlier.
But I realized this when
hanging out with Connor,
how much of a normie Connor is
compared to both me and Joey.
(Joey laughs)
Like, how's it feel-
- What re you saying?
- We're saying you're a normie.
- How does it feel for you hanging out
with like people like us, I guess?
- What do you mean people like you?
- We're a different breed apparently.
- Why do you think I'm
a normie, first of all?
- Okay, because-
- You don't care about
anime as much as we do.
- I care about anime.
- You care about anime,
but you only go so deep into the culture
where you don't really get waifu culture,
you don't really get a
lot of, like, VTubers.
- No comment.
Is VTubing part of the culture?
- I think it is.
I mean, it grew out of
the anime culture, right?
- I mean, you know, you
gotta kind of have a like,
an appreciation, for anime
in order to watch anime girls streaming.
- I mean, I guess.
I don't know.
- How deep do you say
your anime fandom goes?
- That's a weird question.
- Could you frame me maybe scale
or something that you can judge me by?
10 being a fake fan.
- Okay, one is like,
you know, I watch "Attack on
Titan" and "My Hero Academia."
Like, just getting started level.
And 10 is like, I look at an anime,
and I know exactly who the
Genga artist for this is.
- Fuck that.
What are you on that scale?
Where would you put
yourself actually then?
This might help me.
- Like, a seven or an eight I would say.
- I would put myself
as a seven or an eight.
- It probably would have been like a five,
but now it's probably like a four,
maybe even a three honestly.
It's probably gone down to
a three, you know, recently.
- Do you feel like you've
become less of an anime fan,
like, more recently?
And have you like falling
out with the culture
ever since you moved to Japan?
- I guess, I guess because...
- I mean, it's not like
you don't watch anime.
Like, you still keep up
to like all the stuff.
- I love anime memes,
I love otaku culture,
I love like the community in general.
But I think just when
you get so deep into it
and the community, I just start to, like,
not enjoy the community
when it got into a point
where it was getting really deep
and everyone was like, "Name
your favorite key animator."
And I was like, what, who cares?
I like the show and the story.
Why do I need to care about that?
- I mean, we can argue that
Garnt and I are probably
at that point too,
but if someone came up to me and said,
"Name your favorite key animator,"
I'd be like, "Fuck if I know."
- I think there was just a lot
of like, at least when I was,
I don't know if it's still going on.
I mean, you guys can tell me,
but when I was trying to
get really deep into it
and I really wanted to
learn more about it,
it got very, like, gatekeep-y at a point.
- Yeah, it definitely did.
- It's been like that
for a while to be honest.
- To where I just started to,
like, not really enjoy it.
And then I realized,
I think I just enjoy these shows way more
when I'm just casual.
- I mean, I just kinda
learned to appreciate it more
and kind of get deeper into it
without really interacting
with the community around it.
- Well, I guess for a lot of people,
I think me included,
when I get into something the one thing
that I will always do is just, like,
look at the community for it and be like,
all right, what's the norms?
What should I get into?
What's everyone saying
like the best thing?
Because that's a way of
like guiding your, like,
it's like a tailored experience of, like,
what everyone thinks are the
best way of enjoying something.
- 'Cause I feel like
you don't really follow
seasonal anime anymore.
You just kind of wait to see
what everyone's talking about
and what's worth watching.
Like, how do you decide
what anime to watch?
- But I think that's because, like,
the seasonal experience of viewing anime's
kind of like died almost.
- I don't think so.
- I don't think people nearly
talk about seasonal anime
in a week by week way like they used to.
- I disagree.
I just think it's because
last year was, like,
so dry for seasonal anime
that there was just nothing
for people to talk about.
- It was just a lot of
mid shows last year.
- I just feel like now,
especially with, like,
Netflix coming and releasing
the episodes in batches.
Everyone is like, it's not, you know,
"Did you watch the latest
episode of Beastars?
"Did you watch Beastars?"
- But, like, that's like one
out of every fuckin' 100 anime
that comes out every year.
- I feel like everyone asks that now.
It's not, "Did you watch
the newest episode?"
It's "Are you watching Attack on Titan?"
- I would say like,
people are still asking,
"Are you watching the newest
episode of Attack on Titan?"
- People just say "Are you
watching Attack on Titan?"
Not, "Are you watching
the newest episode?"
- Literally every stream
I do, there's always,
it's like, "Have you watched this anime?"
- "Attack on Titan" is different.
"Attack on Titan" is like-
- No, not "Attack on Titan."
Like, any seasonal anime.
- No, normally I never get
seasonal anime people asking me.
- Oh, I get that all the time.
- No one gives a fuck
if I was watching, like,
Oriomon, what is that called?
What the fuck is it called?
What's it called?
- "Oreimo."
- That's it.
Who the fuck gives a shit?
- Were you trying to say
"Oreimo" and "Doraemon?"
- Yeah, who gives a shit?
- That's cursed.
- Generic feels good anime
that's an eight season, you know,
like, are you watching that?
No one asks me fuck if
I'm watching that shit.
No one asks me if I watch "Deca-Dence."
You know what I fuckin' mean?
Like, no one gives a shit
'cause there's so many
animes that are so mid now
and there's so many coming out.
- God, I remember "Deca-Dence."
I tried watching that.
- There's so many animes
that are coming out
that the only ones people,
I seem to have that,
because it used to be,
again when there's a
lot less anime as well,
that everyone could kind of ask
are you watching these shows?
Are you watching it weekly?
And now there's just so fuckin' many.
And we have so many like good shows
but like we only really,
I find in my experience at general,
Twitter only really asked
if you're watching a show weekly now
or keeps up with the hype,
if it's a big event
like "Attack on Titan."
- Right, right, right.
'Cause I feel it was missing last year was
that fuckin' big event.
'Cause last year we had something
like the "Demon Slayer,"
that "Demon Slayer"
episode that really like-
- But even then I never saw,
like, week by week plays
by "Demon Slayer."
- Week by week plays.
(Garnt laughs)
- "Yo, Demon Slayer episode 17!
"Boys, what we all sayin' on Twitter?"
You know, there wasn't like any of that.
It was just episode 19 was amazing.
It gave the birth of my children.
Jesus Christ is re reborn.
Like that's what happened.
That was it.
Like, there wasn't anything else
other than like, "Demon Slayer good."
That was it.
Do you not think that's kind
of like, it shifted a little?
Am I seeing something you guys aren't?
- I think maybe it's just shifted
just because you've kind
of shifted away from it.
'Cause I've also shifted away from it too.
And I've definitely
noticed like the lack of-
- I do feel like that's so many people
'cause I know so many
people now who, like,
they say they're anime fans-
- It shifted to manga, 100%.
- And all they do is read
manga, watch VTubers,
and play gacha games.
- Wow, I'm in this photo and I hate it.
(everyone laughs)
That's literally me!
That was me in 2020.
- I never see people talk
about "episode three of this."
It's always "chapter this of this manga."
'Cause everyone knows that
they're released at this point.
And then everyone keeps
up with it on Twitter.
But I never see it for anime.
No one does anime episode reviews anymore
except for like big shows
like "Attack on Titan."
Everyone does manga chapter things still.
They're so popular.
I genuinely think it's shifted.
I don't think I'm the weird one here.
I think you guys can't see the truth.
What's happening?
- I disagree with, like,
"no one does episode reviews anymore."
- Not really.
- 'Cause there's still like
a big group of YouTubers
who still do it.
- Oh really?
You watch episode reviews?
Name every episode reviewer right now.
- Chibi.
- Chibi's probably the only person I know.
- Chibi's the only one.
- YouTube will be taken down
and Chibi will still be making reviews.
I don't know who like, come
on, that doesn't count, man.
- That's the only one that
matters in my opinion.
- I guess, I mean-
- I feel like that kind
of mirrors the culture now
because I feel like definitely
being an anime YouTuber
last year was fuckin' hard.
Anime content last year was, like,
from my perspective,
anime content on YouTube
just didn't do as well.
'Cause no one was watching any anime.
But videos around anime culture,
like what you guys were doing,
you guys fuckin' killed it
last year, in my opinion.
And I feel like that's because, like,
people care less about
individual shows now.
And people just more
care about the culture.
- I think the last time
I did a show or a video
on a show that was like seasonal
and ongoing was fuckin'
"Promised Neverland."
And that was what, two years?
Three years ago almost.
- I think mine's like "Banana Fish."
It's fuckin' amazing.
- It was like two or
three years ago, right?
And it's like, since then,
it's just like every season comes around
and I do a what will I be watching?
And then I look at the
list and I was like-
- The biggest lie of the century.
- Joey needs to change the title to
"I Lied to You For 20 Minutes Straight."
(everyone laughs)
- "What I'm Looking At."
- I love how the comments
have finally called you out
on it though.
They're like, "Don't fucking lie to us."
- Yeah, of course.
No, that series now is just
a fuckin' quick easy way
of being like, "Oh, let's see
what Joey thinks about this.
"We know he's not gonna watch it,
"but at least we'll know
what he feels about it."
- For me, seasonal anime has just become
this glorified manga
recommendation system.
(Connor laughs)
Where if I find a series
like this, it's so rare-
- This is what, like,
shopping is to Amazon.
I go to the store to go
and buy it on Amazon.
(everyone laughs)
- 'Cause most of the
time you find an anime
and it's like, we talked
about this before,
where it's not an
adaptation that's amazing.
It's a passible adaptation
where I'm just, like,
I don't get anything more than this
from, like, watching the anime
versus reading the manga.
So you just end up reading the manga.
"Jujutsu Kaisen" is like
one of the few, like,
"Jujutsu Kaisen," "Jojo,"
and like some of like
the big shonen ones are
one of the few exceptions
where they actually have budget
and money behind this to make this
a fuckin' amazing production.
You know what I mean?
But for the most part
you have a production
that's just mediocre.
It's okay.
- They're just there.
- They're just there, and it's just like,
I'd rather just read
the manga and get ahead
and speed run this stuff.
- Yeah, honestly.
Like, that's how I've
kind of found myself too.
And also like, you know,
at least very unique
opportunity for me is that like,
I can read 90% of the shit
that hasn't come out yet.
You know?
So it's like, why not just
get ahead on that shit?
- Do you feel like you'd read more manga
if you could actually read it physically?
Or do you not care?
- Probably would.
Although I would annoy me
having fuck tons of manga
at my house 'cause I've read it.
I'm not really gonna read it again.
- Call Joey out like that.
- I'm in this photo and I hate it.
- How often do you pick up
a manga and just read it?
- Every day.
- That's a fuckin' lie.
I was ready for that.
- I'm not joking.
I have to because I have so
many that I've yet to read.
- But, you never reread the
ones you've read, right?
- Sometimes I do.
- Why?
- Because I like it otherwise
I wouldn't fuckin' buy it.
If there's a new manga I pick up-
- Maybe if I could speak
Japanese, it'd be a different.
- If there's a new manga I pick up,
and I pick up new manga
all the fuckin' time,
because it's like, "Oh, I
don't know anything about this.
"This just came out.
"Might be good."
And I buy it.
And I don't like it, I resell that shit.
- Rewatching media to me
feels like playing, you know,
casual games on, you know,
when there's a ranked playlist.
It's like, why would I waste
my time on this casual game?
- Yeah, but you never casual game.
- Exactly.
- I casual game all the time.
- To me when, you know-
- I'm just built different.
- Back in the day when you'd meet a girl,
and you'd be like,
"Oh cool, yeah, what movie
do you want to watch?"
Just like, "Let's watch White
Girls, my favorite movie.
"I've watched it like 15 times."
Like, 15 times?
Why?
Why would you watch "Frozen" 16 times?
Did you get something the
16th the time that you,
you know why?
- I mean, I've seen "Pulp
Fiction" about 30 times
- Okay, movies like that
where you miss a shit tons,
I get it to go back.
But you ain't missing any like deep themes
from "Frozen" or "White
Chicks," you know what I mean?
Like, come on.
- I feel like part of the
allure of rewatching films
or media with people you
haven't watched it before-
- Okay, with people who haven't watched.
I understand that.
- Yeah, yeah.
Because I feel like the only time I
actually rewatch something now is
when I'm with someone who
hasn't watched this show.
You're just like waiting
for their reaction.
Just like, "Oh, oh, oh.
"The big part's coming up."
And they're on their phone,
and it's like a heartbreak.
It's like fuckin' heartbreaking to you.
You want to politely say,
"Pay the fuck attention, you scrub!"
But like, you don't want to
sound like an asshole, you know.
- That is my fuckin' pet peeve, dude.
And the worst is like,
I remember one time I was showing,
I forgot what movie it was to Aki,
and, you know, she was like really quiet
for like the first hour.
I'm like, "Oh, she must be
really paying attention."
I look over she's fuckin' asleep.
(Garnt laughs)
I'm just like, this is so sad, Alexa.
- Doesn't she make you,
like, watch Disney movies
all the time?
- Okay, to be fair though,
I wouldn't watch half the movies
that she shows me unless it,
but at least the good thing
is 80 to 90% of the movies
she actually does show me,
they're actually pretty good.
- I think if you asked me,
would I rather be
interrogated in Guantanamo Bay
or have a girlfriend who's obsessed
with Disney or Kingdom Hearts?
I think I'd take Guantanamo Bay.
I think I'd have more
chance of staying sane.
I cannot stand girls
who always just want
to watch Disney movies.
It drives me insane.
That's like 90% girls.
- No!
- I'm sorry for you, Joey.
That's my nightmare as well.
- Okay, I thought I was
gonna hate it but then again,
I've seen so few Disney
movies, understandably.
- I'm so glad that girls
are moving away from that
and getting into true crime now.
I can get behind girls
wanting to watch true crime.
- No, no, no.
- My fucking god!
- If anything I would
rather watch Disney movies
than true crime.
- No, I love true crime!
- No, I would have to
go with the true crime.
- But you don't understand Aki.
Every morning I wake up
to some kind of police
interrogation tape audio.
- Same here!
- Joey wakes up and is like,
"Is it a rapist today, honey?"
- Every time he's just
like, "So why did you do it?
"So why did you do it?"
I don't want to wake up to this!
- It's that criminal
psychology channel, right?
That I swear every girl is watching now.
- Jim Can't Swim Psychology.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But there's so many of them.
There's so many channels like that.
And I'm just like-
- 'Cause I watched the
Jim Can't Swim Psychology
and then the recommended was just,
it's like the new reaction YouTubers.
They're all reacting to interrogations.
And I'm like, what is happening?
Why are we reacting to interrogation?
- Like, I get it because you watch it
and you almost feel physically suffocated.
Because I remember watching
some of these videos
and you feel like a kid again,
where you, you'd like stole a cookie
and your mom's like,
"Did you steal a cookie?"
And you're just like, "Oh, what do I say?
"What do I say?"
And it's like that simulator
without being back in that-
- They have the thing.
They'll pause the interrogation
and be like, "This is the backward Suplex
"mental gymnastic move."
And I'm like,
I love it when my mother
used to do that one to me.
Or like, "This is the alter
ego sufficing technique."
And I'm like, loved it
when my dad did that to me.
That's a classic.
I love that one.
- Yeah, it's like being
back in school, you know.
Getting told off for detention.
- 'Cause the detectives would be like,
"We have proof."
And they wouldn't say the proof.
And I'm like, this is like
the big mind game at school.
Like, "We know you did it."
I'm like, "Bullshit you do.
"You got no proof.
"No proof!"
- And then they would go,
"We don't need to show it.
"Just know that we have it."
(everyone laughs)
- They're just shitting their pants.
- And just seeing like
good cop bad cop in action
and seeing it actually work.
And it's just, yeah.
I can see how you can
fall down that rabbit hole
and become addictive.
- I do like it, yeah.
- It's interesting, don't get me wrong.
But every day?
- Yeah, honestly, I could
probably watch it everyday.
- Every fucking morning?
- I couldn't do it every day.
- It's not something I want to watch
first thing in the morning.
- I would rather watch
a mediocre documentary
over a good movie.
- You have programmed your brain wrong.
You literally have
programmed your brain wrong.
- That just doesn't make sense.
- I just like real life
stuff way more than like,
I don't know why.
I've somehow gotten into it
where I just really enjoy
like stories of real people.
- But like here's the thing,
because I've thought about this recently
where I feel like a lot of
people now are more, like,
will be more willing to watch something
that they don't have to
pay 100% attention to.
So if you have like a
really high quality movie
or something that you need
to like pay attention to,
you're less likely to watch that
then say fuckin' Trash Tastes, you know,
just three people chatting
shit for two hours
or like a real life documentary
where not every detail is important.
You just get like the
basic story around it.
- That's fine.
I don't know why I'm like that.
I just enjoy it.
I'm sure there's people
out there who are the same.
Like, 'cause on Netflix I
think all I watch is, like,
documentaries.
- Every time I meet you you
watch a new documentary.
I have no idea where you
find the time to do that.
I play a lot of them in the background.
- Yeah.
- But does that count as watching it?
- Well, like I said, some of them are mid,
so it's like just put it on the background
and let it do its thing.
- That's the one thing I've
never understood is, like,
people who say like, "Yeah,
I've watched like 500 movies."
I'm like, "Oh, how did you watch it?"
"Oh, I just let it play in the background
"while I was like cleaning."
Does that count as watching the movie?
- I'm, like, I'm typing out
while it's in my peripheral
and I'm listening to it.
- I dunno.
I don't really count that as watching it.
- What?
Fuck off.
That's watching
- I can't concentrate on it.
- It's watching,
but you couldn't do that to
something like "Pulp Fiction."
- No, God, no.
That's why I would never
treat it like that.
Same with anime.
- And I feel like doing that,
I've realized that because
I've been doing that more often
with YouTube videos as well,
and I've found it harder and
harder just to fuckin' sit down
and watch something.
Like, do you find that like watching,
unless it's like a super engaging show,
like watching any standard show now
it's just 10 times harder
'cause you kind of just want to skip to
where the important plot points are.
- Sometimes.
I mean, I've been watching
some pretty good shows recently
that I haven't really had trouble with,
but yeah sometimes I have that problem.
- I'm glad I've never
subjected myself to that
'cause otherwise I'd probably
be feeling the same pain.
But I don't put something on
unless I have the full intent
of putting 100% of my
concentration into it.
- Oh man.
- 'Cause I don't know.
Like, I don't see the point
of like working on something
while something else is
playing in the background.
'Cause then I'm just gonna get distracted
by whatever's playing.
So either way I can't
concentrate on watching the thing
and doing whatever the fuck else.
- I can't focus without some noise.
- Yeah, I just put music on.
- I mean, music or put something on.
It's whatever.
- Yeah, but like I can't have anything
that's like visual on.
You know what I mean?
- What's the last thing you put on
that you properly concentrated on?
Was it "The Boys?"
- Yeah, I watched "The Boys."
- "The Boys" was a good TV show.
- That was really fuckin'
good, really good.
- That was really fuckin' good.
- I've heard good things about that, yeah.
- I was like, I didn't reach
out my phone or anything.
I was just watching it the whole time.
Season one was really fuckin' good.
- That's the kind of experience I want
whenever I watch something.
'Cause I've been noticing
I've been getting
so distracted recently when watching stuff
that I just I enjoy it less,
and I miss the enjoyment I
had when I guess I was a kid.
- Are you one of those people
who, like, can't be watching something
unless they have, like,
their phone in their hand?
- I didn't used to be like that.
I've slowly become that
person, you know what I mean?
And doing that on anime is hard mode, man.
- Because you gotta read the subtitles.
- Because I gotta read the subtitles!
My fuckin' god, it's like
trying to watch "Monogatari"
when you're eating something.
Like, it's so fuckin' difficult.
- It's like, "Wait, I missed
the one second of dialogue
"that was important
"because of the crunching
sounds in my ears!"
- Yeah, I don't really do it with anime
'cause anime, again, you have to focus.
Can't get distracted,
which is why I think I find I don't watch
as much anime as I used to
is 'cause it is kinda like-
- That's why watching anime
on Netflix is so much easier
because you watch the
dub and it becomes, like,
same type enjoyment now.
- Hell yeah.
- But watching subbed anime,
watching seasonal anime has
just become that much harder
because of that exact reason.
- Going back to the debate
about, am I a real anime fan?
But like, 'cause you mentioned something
you said like VTubers, whatever,
anime, manga, gacha games.
Why do you feel like gacha games is, like,
a big part of being an anime fan?
- Because gachas originally
fuckin' from anime.
The Japanese kind of invented it.
- Yeah, but it doesn't mean,
it's not that deep in anime culture.
- No, it kind of is.
- You can be an anime fan without
ever playing a gacha game.
- Yeah, of course.
But you can't play,
but you very rarely play a gacha game
without being an anime fan.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I mean there's plenty of original, like,
gacha games out there that
aren't anime based at all.
- Yeah, but how many
people play those compared
to the anime based gacha games?
- Well, I mean,
is Genshin Impact an anime game?
- How is Genshin Impact not an anime game?
- Well, I would consider anime being
like the actual like manga anime shows.
- No, no, no, no.
- I'm more talking about
like the anime art style.
- The Arknights.
They weren't based off anything.
- Same with VTubers, right?
Like, I would say who's watching VTubers
who's never watched anime before?
You know what I mean?
- A confused dad.
That's who's watching it.
- I like the gacha games.
I mean, I really enjoyed
Arknights when I was playing that.
I don't really play it anymore.
But like, and Genshin was fine.
I didn't like how I couldn't skip
any of the fuckin' dialogue.
I think they added that now though.
- They've added that now.
- I literally rage quit one of my streams
'cause there was so much
dialogue and it wouldn't stop.
Like, and you would walk 10
seconds to get another dialogue
for two minutes.
This is taking the piss.
This is ridiculous.
No one can enjoy this.
- Yeah, I want to see
you play Yokis again.
You'd probably lose your fuckin' mind.
- I'd be like, "What is happening?
"What is going on?"
And like, (sighs) I don't get it
how people can get excited for
every new fuckin' gacha game.
- I think that's a question
you have to ask Tectone.
- We've also been brainwashed
into being excited for rates
that are higher than 2%.
We're like, "Boys, boys,
it's practically 50/50.
"It's practically-"
- Once it's above 2%, it's
basically a guaranteed draw.
- I feel called out now.
- They've all memed it so much
that they're actually like
proud of it when it's like 2%.
They're like,
"They're practically giving
the five stars away."
Like, do you know what I mean?
- That's practically a guaranteed draw.
(everyone laughs)
- A lot of the stuff,
I just hate how games have just
completely normalized, like-
- Microtransactions?
- To death, yeah.
Like, I enjoyed Arknights.
It was fun, but like, you know,
I'd spent like 800 bucks on that game
and there was still some
missions I couldn't do.
And I'm like, "How much do I need to spend
"to be able to like do
the hardest missions?
"Tell me.
"How much?
"It's ridiculous."
- Just turn your brain off
and just enjoy the game,
and you'll just enjoy the experience.
- You can't because
then it fuckin' is like,
"Beep beep, you got no
fuckin' resources left.
"You want to pay?
"You want to pay a little
money to keep playing, do you?"
Like, I hate that
- I would say the only
real gacha game I'm playing
right now is Genshin.
And my biggest problem with
Genshin has nothing to do
with like the gacha system
even though the pull rates suck ass.
But I mean, like if the
drop rates are fuckin' ass,
then I don't go into
it with a mentality of,
"I'm going to get this character,"
or "I'm going to get this person."
When you come in with
expectations, that's when you lose.
- It's like walking into
a casino being like,
"I'm gonna win the jackpot."
- My actually biggest problem
with Genshin right now is that
when you reach the end game,
it really feels like
you reached the end game
because you are, like,
you're squeezing out content
that's just not there.
- Yeah, we went over that.
- It's become so apparent with Genshin
as opposed to other gacha games
'cause I'm sure we've
played enough gacha games
that you reach that point where you-
- You open into the
dailies and you're like,
"I got nothin' to fuckin' do."
- This is just a part-time job.
I'm fucking grinding away.
- I gotta clock in on my daily.
- I'm just watching numbers go up.
But it's less noticeable
when it's a phone game.
But when it's on Genshin
'cause I dunno how fuckin'
people play Genshin
on the phone, man.
- Disgusting.
- How you do storm terror
or the fuckin' wolf boss
on your phone, that's fuckin' beyond me.
But, like, it feels so weird
when I got to the end game in Genshin,
and I would log on for like
an hour a day on the PC.
And I would just, like,
I would just grind and I
will do nothing but grind.
'Cause I'd gone through all the, like,
the actual content of the game.
And it really feels, like,
it's really apparent on Genshin
because it feels like
the first real gacha game
that should be played on console,
and it feels more like an RPG.
Whereas if it's a mobile game,
I mean, you can do it whenever.
You can do it in your free time.
- Yeah, because I mean,
I definitely felt like when
I was grinding Arknights,
and I was over leveled
for a lot of things,
even though I still
couldn't beat some stages,
like, 'cause you would do it daily
'cause you've been conditioned to, like,
get your daily rewards, man.
Get them.
To the point where anytime
any new content ever came out,
I fuckin' steamrolled
it, like, immediately.
I was like, well that was
like two hours of fun.
I waited three months
for that content update.
- I do feel like a bit like Pavlov's dog.
You know what I mean?
Where it's just like, "Ooh, good, good."
- New content, new content!
- And it's just like,
you can't shit on these games
and like, say, "Oh man,
yeah, it's super grindy.
"You know, the microtransactions
are a little bit much."
Whatever.
And then people are always
so quick to like defend them.
And I'm like, just admit that it's shit,
and what they're doing is
like, you get a free game
and then you have to
put up with this shit.
And they're like, "Well,
I'm free to play."
I don't give a shit if
you're free to play.
Other people are out there
spending a thousand dollars.
Why is it okay if it's just
you're fuckin' free to play?
That's always the excuse
you see this shit.
It drives me insane.
- Like as long as I'm not paying money.
- People are like, "What do you mean?
"I'm free to play.
"I've never had any difficulties."
It's like, well good on you
that you have willpower.
- I mean, I'm one of
those people honestly.
- What, free to play?
- No, not free to play,
but I'll defend the fact
that you can play these
games being free to play
because all you need is willpower.
And you know-
(Joey laughs)
Shut the fuck up.
- All you need is the power of friendship.
That's all you need.
- I mean, if I wanted to,
I could be free to play.
I just don't want to.
- I don't know.
I feel bad for the people
who physically like can't
control their gambling.
- Yeah, I mean-
- They shouldn't be playing it.
- But they should not be
playing games like this.
And I feel like these
games should really come
with a warning.
- Tell that to Tectone.
- But yeah, exactly.
There should be, like, heavy
warnings on games I think
to like say, "Hey listen,
you can spend a grand
"and come out with PNGs."
What was that?
What're you looking at Garnt?
(fly buzzes)
Okay, sorry.
There should be like a
heavy warning saying,
"Listen, you can spend a
grand for like an animation
"and PNG that gets you a
little bit of serotonin."
Like that's.
Like, no money involved.
Like, gambling totally fair.
I just, it angers me so much.
How, like, I don't know.
- You just don't see
the value in those PNGs.
- That's just the new generation, right?
What would you want to pay for it?
Do you want to pay for more money?
Nah, I'll pay for a
little bit of serotonin.
- People don't often,
you never hear people, like,
defending gambling odds.
They're just like, "Yeah, dude.
"It's what it is.
"Gambling is what it is.
"You go in there and it's fucked.
"And yeah, if you want to
go and waste your money."
- House always win.
- But in gachas everyone's like,
"Oh no, actually."
Like it's, everyone's like,
I guess 'cause the option
there is free to play.
- There's no free to play gambling option.
(everyone laughs)
- Well actually, some
casinos give you free drinks
if you just turn up.
Let's go.
I guess that's the
equivalent of free to play.
"I'll have an orange juice please.
"No gambling."
- That's the equivalent of
like free ten pull today.
(everyone laughs)
- Yeah, and they are generous.
But I guess, if you don't
have a gambling addiction,
you can't understand
how it feels to have a gambling addiction.
And I get it why some people
might just want to play a game.
Don't know that it has
like gambling in it maybe,
essentially.
And then they get, like,
kind of tricked into it
'cause they've been weaned on the game.
- That's just modern apps in my opinion.
- It sucks though!
- Because we've just found a way
to literally hack our brains.
Like human beings,
like, we'd like to think
that we're not predictable, right?
But like, five, 10 years ago,
can you imagine like, just
having most of your life,
most of my life now is
scrolling down on something.
You know what I mean?
Most of my life when I'm
not talking to you guys,
I'm scrolling down on some
kind of fucking timeline.
It's never ending.
- Yeah, I get it.
We'll get into some
philosophical stuff here, Garnt.
But back to the point of gacha, right?
The other thing that we've done is
that we've done the best
thing that we could ever want
for these companies.
We've memed spending money.
Nobody wants to feel bad for wasting $200
and not getting what they want.
So what do you do?
You go to Twitter, you tweet
out how you didn't get anything
and you may pick like the pain
Peko or whatever it's called.
- The pain Peko.
- Is that what it's called?
I'm such a fucking boomer!
- You sound like a dad.
- That's like a dad
trying to describe a meme.
- "Hey son, pain Peko."
- "What is that pain Peko?
"Oh, that is a pog
champ right there, son."
- I am not a boomer!
(everyone laughs)
Garnt, stop meming about me
being a boomer for one second.
Listen, we have all
like tricked each other
into making gambling,
like, a community event
and like enjoying it
because no one wants to lose alone!
- Because we share the pain, right?
- We share the pain Peko.
- We've done exactly what
these companies wanted us to do
which is make, like, the gambling
into a form of acceptance.
You haven't joined the gacha community
unless you've fuckin' gambled 1,000 bucks
and haven't got the one with thick thighs
that you forget about three months later.
Fuck!
- No, are you telling
me that part of, like,
the gambling experience,
like you go into a casino,
I remember the last time I
went to a casino with you.
- Great time
- Great time because you got to,
you fuckin' egged on Eugene
to, like, lose his money!
You thought it was fuckin' hilarious!
- That was funny.
- Eugene's our friend.
- So you basically did the exact same.
- No, no, no.
What happened was, you know,
at the time he didn't have a job,
and we were telling him, you know,
"You probably shouldn't
be spending your money."
I was like, you know, I kept playing.
I didn't lose much like 100 bucks.
I was spending that much.
And he wanted to keep up with me,
and I was like, "If you
want to, you can go ahead.
"But you don't have to do it."
- I don't know, man.
That sounds very suggestive to me.
It's the reverse psychology.
It's like, "I'm going to do a 10 pull.
"I mean, you don't have to do a 10 pull.
"I mean, it's a raid up today."
- I'm not streaming me going to a casino
and being like,
"Hey guys, let's fuckin'
gamble on blackjack.
"Pog, man, go blackjack."
- It's the equivalent though.
- I mean, it is the equivalent of that.
I mean, like I said,
gacha is a waifu casino.
- Can you stream gambling?
Poker, I know.
- Yeah, there's poker, there's blackjack.
- Can you?
There's pretty heavy rules
around it though, right?
- Yeah, probably.
- But there's not heavy
rules around gacha.
- No.
- Why not?
Should there be?
- I don't know maybe.
- There honestly should be.
I think there should be some regulations.
- I feel like the biggest
thing about gacha is
that people should know
what they're getting themselves into.
- People should know a lot of things.
That's why people should
also have the option
to tell casinos, "Hey, can you ban me?
"Because I have no self-control."
There's no way to do that with gacha.
- Is that an option with casinos?
- Yeah, in every country you can do that.
- So what you're saying is we
need to come up with, like,
the gacha police.
- Gacha police!
- Ring, ring, you've spending
too much money on gacha.
- I am dead serious.
There should be something
on the play store
or something that you can be like,
"Listen, I gamble too much.
"Can you please not allow me to spend more
"than like 100 bucks like
a year or something?"
Like, set a hard limit that
there's no way to turn off.
- I agree with you on that.
- Because if you go to the casinos,
you fill out the form says,
"Please ban me from this casino."
They will never let you in ever.
'Cause they have like a database
and a lot of the time, if you,
I think sometimes some
courts require you to do it
for certain occasions,
but it's very popular and common
that people who gamble too much
they what they want to
get that life on track.
You know, because it's,
it's easy to have a lapse
in like willpower and
you go to the casino.
So if 95% of the time, you're like,
"I'm never gambling."
- Basically just chastity belt themselves.
- Basically.
You can say like, "This
is not good for me.
"I'm gonna fill out a form."
- I didn't know you could do that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
In the UK 100%
because gambling is a
huge problem in the UK
for like betting shops and
stuff, so they'll do it.
And you can basically,
if it's a chain as well,
they'll ban you from every chain.
- But like, I do think
you're talking about, like,
a vast minority 'cause
like most of the people
who I've met who are playing gacha games,
they're not like us.
But for us, it's kind of
like, like for me at least,
you know, it kind of
revolves around my job.
You know what I mean?
- You stream, you do it, it gets views.
- Exactly.
But like for most people
that I know that play gacha,
they haven't spent like an
inordinate amount of money on it.
- But like, I don't think
there should be an ability
to ruin your fuckin' life
for pulling anime girls.
Like, we know Tectone, who's
a popular gacha game streamer.
And at one point he used
to play, what was it?
- [Computer] Summoner's War.
- He nearly-
- He went homeless.
- He legit went like financially,
I think he might've filed
for bankruptcy or something.
He went fully broke from gacha games.
That should never be a thing.
That should never be able to happen.
- I remember him telling me that
like it was like a fuckin' war story.
- That should never be a thing
for casinos either, right?
- No, but I mean-
- I agree there should be
more regulations about it.
- There needs to be a gacha police.
That's all we need!
- Again with casino,
it is extremely heavily
regulated and you can win money.
So it makes sense that
you can't have the risk
of winning money without losing money.
But with gacha games (laughs) come on.
- For some people though that
PNG is worth more than money.
- It is to me.
- It blew my mind.
- I'm fucking serious!
- Why?
What's wrong with you?
What happened in your childhood, Garnt?
- 'Cause like I've never cared about-
- Anything.
(everyone laughs)
- Until those PNGs came along.
- I've never cared about winning money
'cause like, you know,
to me money has value.
Like obviously like-
- You can't put a price on.
- You can't put a price on waifus.
That serotonin here when you
win like a fuckin' character
that you're actually
emotionally attached to.
You know what I mean?
'Cause people who win money in casinos,
they're not emotionally
attached to this money.
- I doubt that.
I doubt that very much.
- No, I've had friends who
have actually had actual,
you know, proper gambling
problems as well.
And I remember this, I knew
a friend in a university
who one day won like
10,000 pounds in a casino.
Could have paid off his student loans,
could have been like completely debt free.
And within three weeks he had
spent the 10K, 10,000 pounds.
- On gambling?
- On gambling.
Mostly on gambling.
And I asked him,
"Dude, you could've fuckin'
invested this money.
"You could have used it like more wisely.
"You could have used
it to better your life.
"Why did you spend it on gambling?
"Or why did you spend it so easily?"
And he said, "Because I
didn't care about it."
Because he didn't earn it.
'Cause he had no emotional
attachment to the money
'cause he was just given it.
So to him it just felt like-
- It is the equivalent of
just someone coming up to you
and being like, "Here's 10K."
- A lot of these, you know,
the serotonin hit you get
from these waifus, three months
later you don't give a fuck.
- So, that's on you.
That's your prerogative, dude.
- Do you give a shit
about some of the games
that you pulled for
and got that lovely serotonin
hit like months after?
- No, but I have a nice
memory, you know what I mean?
- He goes to his fuckin', like, wall,
like, "Ah, yes, I remember
the time I pulled-"
- I had a good experience playing, like,
all the gacha games I've played.
Otherwise I wouldn't have
played them in the first place.
- It's like, you know, small,
basically the same as like going
to a fuckin' arcade or something
and, like, putting money into that.
- No.
- Yeah, it is.
- That's different.
- Yeah.
- No, it's different.
- It's like, yeah, you're only, you know,
maybe 100 yen, at a time,
but it's still the same.
It's like why-
- That's the problem is that
you could do 100 yen at a time
and if I wanted to spend 500 bucks,
which I tried to do, it
takes like five hours.
It's a long time.
If you want to spend 10 grand on gacha,
give yourself 20 minutes.
- 10 grand in 20 minutes?
- You probably could.
If you were just buying the
highest option multiple times.
- Speed running
bankruptcy, let's go, baby!
- Like, you could I'm sure, you know.
Like, you see the streamers
who spent like 10 grand
but they're making the money back.
Think about all the
people who are doing that
who aren't making the money back.
And yeah, some people are probably
in the financial position
to be able to do that.
But why even give yourself
the chance of like making
that happen to other
people who aren't, right?
Like, and again, you
hear the horror stories
of kids spending their mother's
money and shit like that.
Like, why is this even able to happen?
There should always be
a hard limit built in
that shouldn't be able to like-
- I think that's on the person though.
- Let me ask you this,
what regulations would
you want to see then?
How do you fix this problem
that you've presented?
- I think when you download the game,
and there is gacha in it,
there should be an immediate question
of what is the maximum
you're willing to spend
in like one year?
And you physically no matter what you do
cannot go over that.
Like it will not let you.
- But what if you said zero
and then you change your mind?
- Well, that's on you.
You've already said zero.
- Isn't that the same as just putting
in the credit card numbers
by yourself anyway?
- You've decided zero, you
then can't hurt yourself more,
and you're stuck with the thing
because you agreed to zero.
I think that should be a thing.
- No, because like on the other side then
that means spending money in
essence is also on you, right?
You know, that shifts responsibility
from just one place to another.
- This is the problem.
Like, the problem that
people have with I think
when they're talking about,
like, gambling addicts is
that we don't think of it 'cause
we're not gambling addicts.
We can't think of it as,
"Why don't you just not spend money, bro?"
That's not how it works.
This is the problem is
that I think people alienate these people
and don't even remotely think how it is
to be in their position.
- I totally understand.
But at the same time,
it's what I'm trying to say is
obviously there are people that
are proper gambling addicts
that have a problem that
they, you know, physically,
you know, like cannot control,
have a harder time to control.
But how would you introduce
a system where, you know,
how do you introduce a system
that can regulate that,
you know, as opposed to, you know,
other people who have, you
know, no problem, you know,
having willpower and being able
to control their spending
and financial decisions.
- I do think that there
should be a hard limit
on monthly amount of money
you can spend on any game.
I legitimately believe that.
- I believe that as well.
- I do not think that, like,
anyone should have any excuse
to spend over like $10,000
on a video game a month.
Like that should be just,
that should be like a hard limit baked
into the game or app store.
Something like that.
Because, realistically, no one
needs to spend over a grand.
And if they do,
if everyone's playing by the same thing
of no one can spend over a grand,
the devs won't make games
that are able to get benefit
of spending over a grand,
you know what I mean?
Like, I don't understand
why there hasn't been some
kind of like hard limit
on video game spending.
- Because why would the devs
cuck themselves like that?
- It's in the government's best interest.
- Yeah, no, that's probably
the best solution I can, like,
agree on because I do feel like
there should be a hard limit
on how much you can spend on mobile games.
- I think there should be
something again with like
how you can say, I want
to quit like casinos
because, you know, gambling addicts
probably aren't gambling addicts 24/7.
It's probably like a
lapse of like willpower
where they're like,
"Fuck, I need to gamble.
"I'm depressed," or some shit.
I don't fuckin' know.
I don't know how it works.
But there should be
something in the system
that's like, okay, I want to gamble.
And then you can say that,
or at one point when you
download the game say,
I don't want to gamble.
You can only change this in say seven days
of like, are you sure?
So you say yes, I want to gamble.
All right, come back in seven days.
If you're sure you want to
gamble, we'll let you gamble.
Why not something like that?
- Developers.
(everyone laughs)
- Because most of the money I bet is spent
is everyone's moment of weakness
where they're like, "Fuck
it, I'll spend 100 bucks.
"Let's see what I get, come on."
You know what I mean?
How often would you spend
100 dollars on the gacha
if I had to ask you Joey,
come back in seven days,
tell me you still want
to spend that 100 bucks.
- And I just wouldn't
bother with playing the game
at that point.
- You'd play it free to play.
- Yeah, or not play it at all.
I say more than anything, I'd
probably not play it at all.
- What, if you can't
spend money in the game?
- No, if I'm persistently being
asked, like, are you sure?
Are you sure you want to do it?
I'm just like, I'm not
even gonna bother with it.
- It was that intrusive?
(everyone laughs)
"What do you mean you won't
let me spend my money?
"I'm furious!"
- It's like, leave me alone.
I'll spend it if I want to spend it.
- It's like the opposite now
where they're like,
"Spend money, spend money.
"Get this pack, a deal!"
- Yeah, and I'm in a
position where I'm like,
"I'll get the pack if I
feel like getting the pack."
But I'm not going to if
I don't feel like it.
- But it's the same thing.
What do you mean?
You can just say no to the money thing!
- Yeah.
- You literally just said the same thing.
You're just being an asshole now!
I literally just gave you
the opposite situation
where I was like, "Spend
money, spend money."
And you're like, "I'm fine.
"I don't want that."
- Yeah.
- So what's the difference of saying no?
What?
I feel like you're just
playing devil's advocate
just to piss me off.
- Yeah, I love pissing you off.
It's my favorite hobby
- No, I mean, I can agree.
- That's my serotonin.
- I just think that there's
been way too many cases,
obviously, of people going fuckin' broke.
- How many cases do you know of?
- Yeah, how many do you know of?
- You hear it all the fuckin' time.
- From who?
- I bet if you asked how
many people had, like,
spent a significant
amount of their savings
or like spent too much money, oh, sorry.
Spent an amount of money
that they regretted.
I bet it would be like 50% minimum.
- No.
- We can do it right now.
We can fuckin' do it.
- That's fine.
Let us know on Twitter,
have you ever spent an amount
of money on a gacha game
or video game that you ended
up severely regretting?
- And be honest.
- Be totally honest.
- This is a proper scientific
conduct we're doing right now.
We actually want to know.
- Like, no meme, I'm
actually genuinely curious.
- I love gaming.
I am a gamer, gamers rise up.
(everyone laughs)
- Rise and grind.
- I am a casual gamer.
I just like enjoying my
time playing a video game.
And if I, you know, if
I wanted to, you know,
enjoy my time pulling for some waifus,
then I know that that's on me
because I know that that's
what I'm paying for.
You know what I mean?
- I also, me as well.
I understand that.
I have self control.
- I don't regret any money
that I've ever put into gacha.
From the beginning.
- Would you ever say that
you've fallen for something
that is perhaps like, you know,
not predatory but close to it.
Maybe like they keep offering you stuff,
you know, there's deals constantly.
- Look, I'm not going to lie
and say that gacha isn't just
fuckin' gambling with waifus
'cause it fuckin' is, okay?
But like, I've never seen
the appeal of casinos
because of the reason that I said where,
you know, to me casinos are scary.
'Cause you pay for the
chance to win more money.
And that's like,
that's to me that's like a risk, right?
'Cause that's literally just gambling.
But to me like gacha is I'm
paying for an experience.
I'm paying because I
actually want this thing
that I'm putting money into.
I actually want it.
And it's different where people
are gonna meme this and say,
"Garnt doesn't care about getting money."
That's not what I'm saying.
I'm saying if I'm going to get money,
there are plenty of other ways
that I would want to get money.
- Gambling is the last resort.
- Gambling's the last way I
would use to actually get money.
I wanna work for that shit.
- But there's only one way to get waifus.
(everyone laughs)
- I rarely give a shit
about what memes do.
I'm not like that.
But I guess because we're in the position
where we all have our own job.
We're all old, old people
compared to the zoomers out there.
- And apparently you're the youngest one,
but you're the boomer of the group.
- I feel like a boomer, man.
When I go on Twitter sometimes
I feel like a boomer.
- You are the boomer.
- So, it's all hella normalized, right?
Spending, you know, 100
bucks on a few pulls.
Me and the boys gonna pull a few waifus.
And then, you know, we're
joking about it on Twitter,
you know, we're going to be stream it,
but it's not like, you know,
someone goes to a casino and is like,
"Oh, we do a cheeky like
10 pull on roulette."
And then like everyone's meming it.
"Hey, the classic, you know, bet on red."
We're meming the shit
to like 16, 15 year olds
who are then wanting to do it.
I mean, I don't know.
It feels weird.
- Okay well, what I would say is, okay,
like part of the reason
I've been spending more
on, like, gacha now is
because 2020 has been boring
as fuck or 2020 was boring as fuck.
And I think to myself,
what would I have spent
that money on anyway?
Probably going out and getting pissed.
Like, how much do you
spend on a night out?
- It depends, right?
- How big the sesh is.
- Let's say a standard sesh in
London with the boys, right?
You can spend upwards of like
100, 200 pounds on drinks.
- Fuck, no.
What are you getting up to in London?
- Popping champagnes in London.
- When one single cocktail
in London is like a tenner,
like you start off at like
a Wetherspoons or something.
You know, that's the cheap drinks,
but as you get further and
further on in the night,
people easily spend 100 to
200 pounds on one night.
- Do you get more out of that 10 minutes
of pulling that gacha than a
whole night with your boys?
- I mean, I would say that-
(Connor laughs)
No, no, no, no, no, no.
- What are you, a
politician right now, Garnt?
What is this?
Come on, man.
Answer the question.
- I'm just saying like-
(Joey laughs)
I'm being attacked right now.
- I am attacking you.
- I need to fuckin' defend myself.
I need to fuckin' defend this shit.
- Mister speaker, if I may interject.
- But you know, you say
we've normalized the stuff,
but like, you are fine, for example,
spending that much on a night out
because that's what you choose.
You know, that's what you
choose as the experience,
and that's what you choose
is okay for the price.
You know what I mean?
- So basically what you're
saying is a night out
with the boys is the equivalent
to getting your favorite waifu.
- There's tangible stuff you're buying.
You're buying drinks there.
That is stuff that has to be made.
You're going, you're transporting.
This is all stuff that, you
know, has a cost for a reason.
The gacha it's conflated
because they know they
can get away with it.
They know they can charge
this much for a pull.
- I mean, it's the equivalent of, like,
going out to a bar and
buying a tenner drink
and going home and pouring
yourself that same drink, right?
- No, it's different.
- No, it's the same.
Because like getting your
favorite waifu on a free pull
is the pouring your drink at home.
- No, it's not.
- Yes, it is.
- What's the going out then?
What's that?
- The fuckin' ten pull you pay for.
- What?
No!
- That's exactly what it is!
- Oh my God, this is such low brain IQ.
No dude, okay.
When you go to, like, let's
say you go to a bar in London.
You pay, I don't know, fuckin'
nine pounds for a cocktail.
You're not paying for the ingredients.
You're paying for someone one, to make it-
- You're paying for the experience.
- You're paying for the experience,
you're paying for like,
you know, the glass,
the expertly prepared.
- The glass.
(Joey laughs)
- Do you have nice
cocktail glasses at home?
- No.
- I ain't gonna buy them.
They're like fuckin' 30 quid.
They have really nice ones, right?
Everything you get is tailored experience.
That's where the price goes.
Is it a bit of a rip off?
Yeah, kinda.
But it's not, like, to the point
where I feel like I'm
being taken advantage of.
With gacha games I kind of do.
- But that's just on you.
- No, I feel like they,
I genuinely believe
that, like, gacha games
to some extent are like just getting away
with as much as they can
to take advantage of you.
- Of course it is.
- I'm not gonna say that
they're not getting away with
as much as they can.
I totally believe that
there should be regulations
around this stuff.
That's not the argument here.
- The fact that it took, like,
multiple governments to get involved
just to make them show you
the odds is ridiculous.
Like, how long were
people getting fucked over
'cause they didn't know
the percentage was 0.001?
- A long time.
- A lot of people.
But they probably also didn't care.
- Yeah, but how is it ever acceptable?
Like, that that was okay?
Like casino, you know, the odds.
Like, even casinos aren't that scummy.
They'll let you know.
Like, this is just blows my mind
and how people constantly defend them.
I would be more okay with
if everyone just admitted
it's just one big scam.
And we're all just in for it-
- No, it's not a scam though.
It's not a scam!
- It's like one step away from a scam.
- What's that one step?
- What is a scam for you then?
What is a scam for you?
Because to me a scam is like it means
that you are getting, what's
the word I'm looking for?
Like, the user's in the dark.
We know exactly what we're
getting ourselves into.
And that's why, to me, it is not a scam.
- A scam is like saying like,
"Oh, on this banner,
"the ten pull is a guaranteed six star,"
when it's not a guarantee.
- That's come in to stop any
more government regulation.
'Cause if they were trying
to get away with that for-
- No, that is a scam.
If they're actively lying to the user base
then that to me is a scam.
- Which I'm sure many of
them were at some point.
- But we don't know that.
- I mean, come on (laughs)
- The best weapon against
that is just education, right?
It's like-
(Joey laughs)
No, no!
- DARE, don't do drugs.
- Just have a wrinkly
brain, that's all it is.
- Like, I meme it the fuck up,
but if you want me to talk
about the realities of it,
I will talk about the
fuckin' realities of it.
And that's because I don't want,
I know exactly what I'm
getting into with gacha games.
And I know what my limits are.
- I do think it's gotten
much better since they've,
one, you get a guaranteed
and, you know, you get to see the rates.
That's much better.
That's increased it a lot.
- Like, I meme the fuck up
that I'm like spending money on, like,
literally a fuckin'
0.6%, but that's on me.
- You're in a financial
position to be able
to make that decision though.
- But even if I wasn't,
you know what I mean?
- That's on the person.
- Not always.
I think sometimes depending on how,
we're going in circles kind of,
but like depending on how the
game is presented and made
I think sometimes a
fault can be on the game.
- Right.
- And I hate how you can't
even have this discussion
without people being like,
"Oh you're just whining, bro.
"It's free to play any way."
And it's like, it's not that simple.
I think it's never that simple.
- I mean, I feel like if-
- I think not opening the door
to that conversation is irresponsible.
- I mean, for me,
I feel like the conversation
to me, it always ends at
if it doesn't feel like, you
know, your type of game, like,
I don't feel like you
are made for gacha games.
And I genuinely believe that
'cause I feel like someone
with your personality,
like a true fuckin' gamer
just would never enjoy gacha games.
- No, I don't.
I hate that I'm paying
for part of the game.
I hate that.
- I'm completely fine with that.
The reason I love gacha games is
'cause it suits my lifestyle perfectly.
It suits my mentality
when it comes to playing games perfectly.
- He's a true gacha gamer girl.
- I'm not saying that
Gacha shouldn't exist
or anything like that.
I totally recognize that it has its place
and it's got its value.
I just want like everything
to be more transparent.
And there'll be systems in place
to stop people going broke from them.
I don't think anyone should
go broke from fuckin' like,
I don't know.
Fuckin' Arknights.
Are you kidding me?
Like, no one should be going
broke from fuckin' video games.
Why?
Why was that even an option?
- I mean, it shouldn't be an option
and that's what we agree on.
- Right, right.
It's like, we've totally
made it totally memeable
and okay to be like,
"(laughs) He's gone broke.
"What an asshole."
- We haven't memed up people going broke!
- People do, man!
What do you mean?
- But that's not us.
We're not doing that!
- Who's meming?
- Go on Twitter, I bet there's some, bro.
- But Twitter you meme
up fuckin' everything.
- If someone's like,
"(laughs) I just spent
100 dollars on a gacha
"and I pulled nothing."
That's basically like the same
as what you did to
fuckin' Eugene being like,
"(laughs) You just spent
100 pounds on a casino
"and you didn't get anything."
- Also there's nothing on Twitter
that's not getting memed up.
Like, you can scroll
on Twitter being like,
"LOL his dad died."
- If someone has a legitimate problem
and someone's like,
"Dude, I fully regret
spending this much on gacha."
Then I'd be like, "Bro, I feel you."
- Like, sorry.
- "You just got to quit.
"You know what I mean?"
This is bad.
- Well, there's nothing else to say.
- They're gambling addicts for a reason.
You can't just quit.
It's not that easy.
- There's nothing else we can say.
In our position there's
nothing else you can say.
- "Just stop doing drugs, bro.
"Just stop.
"Why're you doing drugs, man?"
Like, it's not that easy.
End of point.
No more.
There should be regulations.
- Bottom line.
Someone needs to make the
gacha police a reality.
- Bottom line there should be regulations.
How strict they are that's up for debate
between gacha players and
pro gamers apparently.
- Pro gamers.
(everyone laughs)
Pro gamer girls and gacha gamer girls.
The never-ending war.
- I think there should be
like a cool-down period, 100%.
That's my closing statements.
Are gacha games predatory?
That's the title.
- Oh my god.
- No.
- Why not?
That's a brilliant title.
- 'Cause then the entire
fuckin' gacha game community is
just gonna destroy us.
- See, that's the problem is
that the gacha gamers get offended
when you insinuate there could be anything
even predatory about it.
Why?
- That's not what we said.
- I know, but why though?
Why do they?
I've seen the moment you
complain about gacha rates,
there are like a hoard
of people being like,
"Oh I'm free to play.
"No, no, no, no."
- Because we hurt their feelings.
- Because basically from a
lot of people's perspective,
it sounds like,
"Oh you're enjoying this thing?
"No, you're not allowed to enjoy this."
You know what I mean?
It's like, why, why are you enjoying this?
It's wrong to enjoy this thing.
- No, no, the games are totally good.
The games are great.
Genshin's a great game.
All chill, whatever you want.
You want free to play?
Cool.
You want to spend money?
But I just think
that there shouldn't be
like predatory systems
on anything to do with video games.
It's like having like a Fisher-Price toy
and being like,
"Do you want to roll
for a new fuckin' toy?
"You want a 10 dollar?"
You know what I mean?
Like, we don't put that shit near kids.
- So you're not the kind
of person who's like,
"Oh, there's a new DLC."
- I don't give a fuck about DLC.
You give me the game as is.
That's what I'm playing.
- You're just a true gamer, man.
- Maybe.
- The most vanilla gamer out there.
- How's that vanilla?
Hardcore, I'd like you to add.
(everyone laughs)
Go and fuckin' play a
fuckin' disguised book
and call it a game, Joey.
- What is your perfect
gaming experienced, Connor?
What is your perfect gaming experience?
- Oh, League.
- No.
Fuck off.
(everyone laughs)
No League player would ever say that.
- Then why do you play it so much?
- That's a good question, Joey.
Addiction.
There should be a systems in place.
(everyone laughs)
- There should be restrictions.
- You meme, but League
addiction is a fuckin' thing.
Don't try to tell me-
- Yeah, you memed that!
- Don't try to tell me League
addiction is not a thing.
It is a fuckin' thing.
- Yeah, but it's not like you,
I mean, you have to try
very hard to ruin your life
with a League addiction.
You have to really be on
that path of ruining it.
But I don't know.
Perfect game for me.
I don't know.
Maybe like something like
one of the Halo games.
It was a very fuckin' good game.
Perfect game experience.
You get a good game.
Maybe some of them had like DLC,
but that's (mutters)
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- Points down for that.
- Yeah, I don't know.
- Are you talking about, like, OG Halo?
- Yeah, yeah, OG Halo.
- Like, Halo one and two.
- Halo one and two are
really fuckin' good games.
Just a game that has an experience
that when it's over it's over.
- What about, like, a current game?
- A current game.
Hades is probably the best
game I've played recently.
That's a fantastic example of a game.
No DLC, no bullshit.
You just play the game.
You know, you get the
story if you want that.
I'm not into that.
(Joey laughs)
That ain't me.
But the gameplay, fuckin' amazing!
- To me, like, 90% of the games
I ever play, I don't finish.
I don't know why.
- Such a fuckin' weak mindset.
- No, no, like, I get to a point during-
- Do you cum during sex?
Or do you just walk out
halfway through, Garnt?
(Connor laughs)
- Does the sex-
- Does the sex take 50 hours?
- Does the sex take 40 to 50 hours?
- Bare in mind I don't play Final Fantasy.
I don't play your coups.
I don't play any of
those long games at all.
The longest game I played
was like fuckin' Blue Dragon
or some shit.
- Like, I have to be properly
invested in this stuff.
And I'm the type of guy who, you know,
I get really into a game
and then I hit around
like the 20 hour mark,
and then I still have a
quarter of the story left
or a quarter of the gameplay left.
And I feel like I've gotten
everything out of that game
that I need to do, and
then I just stop playing.
Know what I mean?
Like, a big reason why I, you know,
even with gacha games
is that if there's not
that reason for me to keep playing
or if I'm not getting
something new out of it,
then I just drop it.
- What do you mean?
It's just a fuckin' daily quest every day.
- Well, sometimes I like the story.
Sometimes I, you know,
sometimes it is, you know,
(Connor laughs)
sometimes you want to get
that grind for that character-
- The moment you said
story he just checked out.
(everyone laughs)
I could see his brain just power down.
- I cannot fathom why
people want to grind.
Like, why do people put
themselves through that?
It's torture.
- I mean, it's kind of like
just that mindless task, right?
- Yeah, it's just something to do.
- You feel like you're-
- Go fuckin' knit or some shit.
- You're telling me that League
isn't a grind after a point.
It's a fuckin' grind.
It's just a grind with
more complicated controls.
You know what I mean?
- No.
- Yes it is.
- There's a loss,
and there's like a win and a
loss have different outcomes.
Grinds there's only one outcome.
You just win.
You just, you do the thing
that you're meant to do.
And then you've already planned-
- Well, it depends how you grind.
- But it's like, all right,
I've got my spreadsheet out.
It's gonna take eight years of grinding
of killing these boars.
- What is-
- Is that how you view every JRPG player?
That we have a fuckin' spreadsheet?
- No, but in your mind it's like,
"I'm gonna do this
mindless task five times
"to get this thing."
- What is the end goal of League?
- There is no end goal.
It's like self-improvement in mechanics.
- Exactly.
- Checkmate.
- That's exactly it.
Because that's my problem
with competitive games.
I, you know, every time I
get to do a competitive game
whether it be League, Overwatch,
fuckin' Valorant, whatever,
is like the golden
period is the first time
when you're learning the game.
And then you started
getting good at the game.
And then you start learning the systems.
And then you start the ranks
playing, you start climbing.
That's when the game is fun.
When you feel like
what you've learnt has had
a tangible effect, right?
But everyone, everyone will hit that wall.
Everyone will hit that wall
where you climb as hard as you can,
unless you're fuckin' faker or something
and you've won like the world tournament.
'Cause that is basically the
only end goal there can be
in any competitive game, to
be the best in the world.
And so everyone will reach a
point where it becomes a grind
because there's no way that
you can overcome that wall
without grinding your way
to overcome that wall.
- Yeah, but that's like
a self-improvement thing.
- And then after you do
that you reach another wall
and another wall after that.
- But it's constantly
like improving a skill,
but in like JRPGs and you know gacha games
often it requires no
skill to do the grinding.
In fact, it requires the opposite.
- But what I'm saying
is you feel like you're-
- But you're working towards a goal.
- You talk about self-improvement,
well you're working towards a goal.
You're gaining something.
To us gacha games is just that.
I mean, like, not just gacha games,
but like I'm pretty sure in like any MMO
when you're grinding,
you just feel like you're making
progress towards something.
You just less-
- That's like fun to people?
- Yeah!
- Just having like the super
easy thing just play out.
And you're like not engaged at all
just because you're
going towards something?
- Yeah, you know, sometimes
I don't want to feel shitty
when I've played five League
games and lost five in a row.
- Yeah, I play games to
have fun, not to rage.
- It's just, like,
you're just activating
the fuckin' neurons.
You don't need to worry about it.
- I just like being challenged constantly.
Like, I want something
that is challenging always.
Like, the moment you grind-
- How do not get tired?
- What do you mean?
I don't know why.
I like being challenged constantly.
- Do you not feel like
competitive games get
to a grind after a point?
Do you not feel like-
- No, it gets to a
point where I feel like,
okay, I genuinely think unless
I put X amount of effort in,
I'm not going to improve at this game.
I normally just quit at that point
'cause I'm like, all right.
I feel like I've gotten
all the challenge I can
out of this game in a
reasonable amount of time.
I'm going to find something else.
- Yeah, and that's
exactly the same for me.
When I reached the point
where I reached that grind-
- Half these gacha games have auto-play,
so what are you doing?
- Sorry?
- What are you doing?
- I'm doing other things.
- Yeah, I mean, that's why, you know,
the only times I'm okay with auto-play is
when it's on a mobile because-
- I'm not fuckin' staring at my phone
while it's auto-playing the entire time.
I'm doing other shit.
- Yeah, but I've been out with you
and your auto playing on the thing,
and you gotta keep track
of it a little bit,
make sure it's all going well.
You're like, okay.
- Yeah, for like two seconds,
and then I'm doing other things.
- You also can't use
your phone in that time
because you are doing the
mission, so you can't reply-
- Oh sorry, I have other things
to do than look at my phone.
- I have emails to reply to, Joey.
I have, you know, messages
I've got to reply to, man.
You know, it's busy life.
- Yeah, I don't know about that.
- I also like not fucking my battery
which is like really
annoying on the gacha games.
When I was playing Arknights,
I had to carry a fuckin' spare
charger with me everywhere.
My battery was fuckin' dying.
- For me when gacha
games stop getting fun is
the moment I start thinking
about optimization.
'Cause when I start
thinking about optimization,
I'm just like, okay, now I'm just like-
- That is the challenge
for me in gacha games.
- That's exactly the point.
- Which is problem.
Because once I figure out
how I can optimize this game maximized,
then it's not fun anymore.
- Yeah, exactly.
Then its not fun!
- But I figure that out immediately
because all the shit's online,
and everyone tells you how to do it.
So once you've seen the spreadsheet-
- So, you basically, like,
just willingly is like,
"I just figured out a way
to make this game not fun."
- There is nothing fun
about pressing auto-play.
That's fuckin' shit.
- When you're opening up a spreadsheets
and you know, actually, thinking
about how to optimize this
and optimize that, that's
when it stops getting fun.
I just like the experience of just doing
like a very simple activity.
I don't need to worry about it.
And I just feel like
I'm gaining something,
and I'm not gonna say that,
"Hey, this is the peak
of all entertainment.
"This is why I play video games."
You know what I mean.
It's just a nice little
thing in the background.
- I cannot understand.
Like, my brain cannot
wrap around the thought
of just I'm just progressing-
- Maybe I'm the monkey
brain in this instance.
- To me, the idea of progressing to a goal
without actually doing anything,
it seems like the dumbest thing ever.
- Why?
- How is it a goal if
you're not progressing?
- Because fuckin' life
is stressful enough, bro.
- What do you mean?
Like, I get rid of my stress-
- Life is already a challenge!
I don't want another
challenge on the side.
- I de-stress by getting
like challenged to do stuff
outside of, like, life.
- No, you're fuckin' weird.
- Because there's no pressure.
If I lose in a ranked
game, I don't give a fuck.
I'm not gonna get my fuckin'
mortgage taken away from me.
Like, it's nothing like that.
- With a mindset like that,
I'm surprised you're not a speed runner.
- No, no, no, no.
- Because that's the exact
same mentality I feel.
- No, no, no, no, no, no.
That's psychotic 'cause that's like,
"I want the same experience
again with a minute difference."
That to me like blows my mind.
- But that's exactly what
I'm hearing right now.
- No, no, no.
'Cause when I get done with
the challenge, I'm done.
I'm on with another game.
Like, these speed runners
will spend like two months
to get a one second optimization.
And I'm like-
- Aren't you all about optimization?
- Yeah, and other things,
but not my like complete my fun.
Like, my fun is learning something
and getting better at it.
Like, I will optimize-
- I mean, wouldn't you say
that that is speed runners
because they're learning a game?
- I think it's almost an
obsessive amount though I think.
Like, I get it 'cause I got
into like speed running Cuphead
at one point.
That was quite fun because I
was seeing good improvements.
But the moment it became not fun is
when I would do a 40 minute run,
and I was just like, "I don't
really know what to do now."
I didn't really see much to improve.
And then I would look on
the line and I'll be like,
"Okay, I guess I can do this."
But then like, yeah sure,
the mechanical aspect
of trying to get better
at like a certain thing was better but-
- But it's a challenge.
- Yeah, but it was not,
when you play against other players,
there's always a constant
direct challenge facing you.
And every second there
is constant decisions
you have to make to outplay.
And every new game is a new experience.
There's a lot of things that are the same.
But with a speed run, I think
the problem I have with it is
that it's always, like,
we follow the formula
and then we try and improve on
the formula little by little
which is not kind of fun
'cause if you're doing, like,
people do like three hour
games that speed runs.
Like, they might do like a
two second optimization here
and then redo everything the same way.
That sounds like insanity to me.
You're not changing anything.
There's no variation.
You're just changing one detail,
constantly trying to improve it.
And sure, I can understand
why that's fun to someone.
But for me I can't do that.
And I just can't get invested in that.
That's just not what I do.
- So what do you get invested in then?
Self-improvement?
- Yeah, self-improvement.
- What is your definition of fun?
- What is fun for you?
- It's a skill.
And then seeing how well
I can apply the skill
on the fly to things.
Like, how well I can learn it
and adapt to situations
is what's fun to me.
I like losing 'cause that
means I can get better.
- See, for me, I play video games
'cause I just like escapism.
- That is my escapism.
- Yeah, to me video games, I
do that enough in my real life.
You know what I mean?
That's probably why I
fuckin' watch so many isekai.
I'm just realizing this now, man.
- Escape to another world.
- But yeah, it's just like,
I want to do something
where it's, you know,
sometimes with gacha games, you know,
there's no way you could
lose at the gacha game
unless you were fuckin' spending money.
But like, in terms of like
the grinding and the progress,
there's no way to lose against it.
- So you just don't like losing?
You don't like losing?
- Who does like losing?
- I like losing.
- You're fuckin' weird.
- No, it's not.
Every fighting game player's
obsessed with losing I swear.
- Yeah, that's why they're all psychotic.
- That's like some martial arts mantra.
- I don't know.
I was playing Mario Kart With someone,
and they couldn't drift on Mario Kart.
And I thought this is
a very basic mechanic.
This is not that hard to understand.
And I was like,
"You should just try it
without the baby mode on."
'Cause I feel like the baby mode
just all you're then doing is holding A.
'Cause the fun part about
Mario Kart is drifting I think.
And nailing drifts, and,
you know, playing the game.
I like drifting in Mario Kart.
Okay, I'm gonna say that
for like the 90th time.
- Do you like drifting in Mario Kart?
- I love drifting in Mario Kart.
- You say that is if it's
an unpopular opinion.
- I was playing with
someone the other day.
And I was like-
(Garnt laughs)
- I'm glad you laughed.
- Yeah, hot take.
I drift in Mario Kart.
(everyone laughs)
- Hot take, hot take.
So they couldn't beat me in Mario Kart.
And I'm like,
"Yeah, it's 'cause you're
not fuckin' drifting.
"You're never going to beat
me if you're not drifting."
And they were like, "Oh,
okay, I guess I'll try."
And they tried it once.
They tried it without baby mode on.
They kept falling off the
edge, and they're like,
"No, I don't like Mario Kart now.
"It's not fun."
I'm like, what did you expect?
That you were just gonna
be amazing right away?
No, you've got to put some effort in?
Start learning how to
drift, you dumb fuck!
Try it!
- The fact that you've
gotten that competitive
over fuckin' Mario Kart just
shows what your mentality is.
- It drives me insane when
people try something like that.
That is not that,
we're not talking about, I'm not like,
"Just get good at StarCraft, bro."
I'm not asking that.
I'm like press one button on Mario Kart
when you come to the corner.
That's all I'm asking.
That's what I'm trying to explain to you.
People who like throw a fit and are like,
"I don't wanna play anymore.
"It's not fun now.
"I failed this one mechanic
and I don't care to learn it."
Like, that drives me insane.
- I can imagine the dad you're gonna be.
Like, "Son!
"You can't drift in Mario Kart.
"You're a disappointment.
"Dead to me!"
- I do not have like, people will be like,
"Wow, Connor's that guy,"
'cause to me fighting
game combos are absurd.
Like, the amount of combos
and inputs you have to
put in is just too much.
Like, there was just such
a steep learning curve.
Again, the fighting game
community will be up in arms
now that I've said that.
They'll be like, "(scoffs) Okay, Connor."
The drifting in Mario Kart is
such a low barrier of entry
in terms of intense mechanics.
- For you.
- No, no.
Is it really?
Do you think it is?
- I know some people who just,
no matter what game it is,
some people just don't,
their brains just don't operate
when it comes to like games.
Even a simple mechanic like drifting,
they're just like, "I
don't understand that."
- I think to me it's, like,
if they had never wanted
to drift, it's fine.
But they wanted to drift
and wanted to learn.
And then it was difficult,
and they gave up immediately.
And that's what annoyed me is
that they immediately gave up.
- Well, I mean-
- How do you get anything done in life?
- But isn't that the equivalent
of you playing Tekken
and being like, "I want to do this combo."
And you try and you're
like, "I don't like it."
- No, I would try the combo
and I'd be fuckin' shit at it.
And I'd get my ass clowned on.
Then I realize I'm just not
getting better at this game.
- That's the exact the same!
That's the exact same thing!
- No, I would try multiple
sessions to get good at it.
- What's the difference?
- It's just the same thing
with a different difficulty curve.
- It's the same thing.
It's the difference of I have one life
versus I have three lives.
Oh, game over, woops.
- This is why I said, I
prefaced right in the start,
I'm like, it's not like
I'm asking you to get good
at StarCraft or anything intense.
I'm not asking you to
learn intense mechanics.
It is Mario Kart drift.
- Yeah, but you have to understand people
for some people that is intense.
- How?
How is that intense?
- It's just how it is!
- I refuse to believe that's intense.
- Are you telling your grandma can fuckin'
figure out Mario Kart straight away?
- If you're my age,
Mario Kart drifting should
not be an intense mechanic.
I think it's like early onset dementia
if that is a problem for you, honestly.
- That's some big claims there, buddy.
- I do not expect my grandma
to even know how to get like,
just click the fuckin' menu
on the Nintendo Switch.
I'm not expecting her to do that.
Very extremely basic
mechanics, like, okay.
Again, this is not my problem
that they can't do it.
It's that they gave up right away.
The first failure of the first track,
they're like, "I'm done, I quit."
- Maybe because they don't want
a fuckin' challenging
experience in a video game.
Maybe they just want to play it for fun.
- You're like the Navy Seals dad.
- No!
I despise those people.
- You're becoming one!
- I would never expect someone
to be good at any video game.
- "Are you trying to say
"that you're playing Mario Kart for fun?
"No, no, no.
"It's all about the challenge.
"It's about the challenge."
- I would never claim to be,
I want to be good at fighting games
and then I'll try and give up.
If I want to actually learn something,
I'm gonna do it.
I'm not gonna throw a hissy fit
and give up when I'm not good at it.
- But, that's just how you operate.
So you have to realize not
everyone is an epic gamer girl.
Some people just don't see games that way,
and you just have to accept that.
(everyone laughs)
- I just think it was annoying.
- No, I get it.
I get like, that's annoying to me as well,
but I'm not gonna get
like pissed off at them.
I'm just like, well, that's
just how you play games.
- That just means probably it
just ain't the game for them.
- It's just not the game for them.
Maybe they just don't like
playing games like that.
- I just genuinely off the top of my head,
I can't think of an
easier mechanic to learn
than the Mario Kart drift.
Can you?
Name an easier mechanic, go right now.
- Probably accelerating in Mario Kart.
(everyone laughs)
- Actually no, it's automatic now, Joey.
- Is it actually?
- Yeah, there's an option.
It's on automatic by default.
So, you don't even have to do that.
- Turning in Mario Kart.
- On baby mode it's automatic!
That's what I'm saying.
There's literally the game play-
- That's what I'm saying.
There's a reason why they
added those mechanics
because for some people
it's just too much.
- That's what I'm saying then-
- They just want their monkey
brain neuron activation-
- To you Mario Kart might be a baby game.
But for some people
it's the equivalent of playing StarCraft.
- I never said it was a baby game.
I'm just saying what happened was is that-
- What you're saying is-
- They were complaining
that I was winning.
I'm like, "You're never going
to win if you don't drift."
So my problem was is
that they're complaining
that I'm winning, I told
them how I was winning,
I explained to them,
this is how you can do it
and how easy of a mechanic it is to learn.
Like, you can learn it in
one sitting very comfortably.
Like, most people would if
they actually just tried.
But they just gave up immediately.
- "Son, just start winning."
- "Just get good!"
- "Son, son!"
"Why aren't you winning, son?"
- "Why aren't you winning?"
- It would never get to that point.
My son would be disowned before-
(everyone laughs)
I would be like, "Why haven't
you won already, son?"
I'm kidding, no.
I don't know, am I being-
- My son was winning out the womb.
- Connor doesn't ask,
"Are you winning, son?"
- Why am I the asshole?
- "You're winning right, son?"
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- Why am I the asshole
for thinking, that's like,
just like, I dunno.
You should maybe just not give up.
- 'Cause you're literally complaining
about competitive Mario Kart!
- No, I'm not complaining about that!
I'm complaining about the part
that they gave up immediately
and were like, "I can't do it."
I hate when people do that.
Like, "I just can't do that."
- I hate it too,
but I'm not like fucking
lose my shit over it.
- I don't give a shit about it.
It's fuckin' Mario Kart.
- If they don't want to win
in Mario Kart that's on them.
- It's fuckin' Mario Kart.
I don't give a shit if someone
gives up in Mario Kart.
- No, but they were having
like a little hissy fit.
And I'm like, "That's your problem, man.
"Stop giving up on shit in life.
"This is why you get nothing done."
- That's why you're not in the Navy Seals.
(everyone laughs)
- That's why you never
excelled at anything, son,
because you gave up the first time!
- If you're getting pissy over
someone losing in Mario Kart
or someone throwing a
hissy fit in Mario Kart,
imagine something more
intensive in life for them.
- No, you guys are
taking it out of context.
I'm saying they were getting pissed off.
And then it kind of pissed me off
that they were getting pissed off about it
because they didn't put any effort in.
- Well, yeah, but like-
- Then you tried to got me
like with a gotcha moment
on fighting games and it's
completely not related at all.
- It is related!
We're talking about-
- You gave me an entirely
different situation.
- No.
- No, no, no, no, no, no.
What we're saying is
that you got pissed off
with someone having a hissy thing.
I wouldn't even bother getting pissed off
at someone having a hissy fit
'cause it's fuckin' Mario Kart.
- It irked me.
- Basically them giving up on
not being able to learn drift
in Mario Kart is exactly
the same situation
as you not being able to
learn the difficulty curve
in the fighting game.
- No, no, no.
It's completely different thing, right?
If that was my own choosing,
and I went through that,
or like someone pushed me on it, like,
"You should start learning combos."
I could totally understand
if I was pushing it on them
but they wouldn't want to do
it or wouldn't be good at it.
Because I mean, I'm putting it on them.
They never wanted to do
it in the first place.
- But you were pushing them to drift.
- No, I never said that.
- Yeah, you did.
- They said, how was I winning?
I said, drifting.
And they were like,
"Oh, I want to do that."
I literally said that.
Stop putting words in my fuckin'
mouth, Joey, you asshole.
What I'm saying is like,
if I was pushed into doing it,
totally understand why
you would then give up.
- Basically you just
hate people who give up.
- I hate people who give up right away.
I hate it, dude.
- What's the right amount
before someone gives up
when it becomes acceptable?
- I mean, you can tell if
you're like good at something
when someone just isn't
getting the hang of it,
and they aren't gonna get a hang of it.
You know what I mean?
Like, if you have been doing
something for a long time,
you can just tell they're struggling.
But like, most people,
like, not most people.
There's a fair amount people out there
who are perfectly capable
of doing something
who just give up immediately
'cause they failed the first time.
- Yeah.
- Probably with you guys
with ranked games I imagine.
- No, I mean, I don't give up immediately.
I just get bored.
- Go and spend your money.
Go and get that serotonin.
- I don't even start 'cause
I know I'm gonna hate it.
I don't even try.
- 'Cause you have a hissy
fit when you lose at games.
- Yeah.
(Connor laughs)
And I don't want to have a hissy
fit when I'm losing a game.
That's not why I play games.
- Why do you get a hissy
fit when you lose at a game?
- Because when does it ever feel-
- Someone has to lose.
- Name me a moment where
I'm like, "Oh man, I lost."
Like, no one says that.
- I don't give a shit
when I lose at a game.
I'm like, "All right, well fair enough.
"I got outplayed, you know.
"It is what it is."
- Does that feel good to you?
- Sometimes if I know
where like I could have-
- The fuck's wrong with you?
- I think it is, like, a
healthier mindset to be of,
"I don't mind losing so I can improve."
- I'm not, I'm not-
- Fuck that is the
complete fuckin' opposite
of League experience, my friend.
The League experience
is, "Fuck me, I lost.
"Was it my fault or was
it my teammate's fault?
"I have literally no fuckin' clue."
- No, I deadass know in League
when it was completely my fault.
I mean, there are some games you know
it is 100% not your fault.
- There are some games when
it's like the 50/50 game,
and then your teammate is
just caught out one V five
while, like, you're all
doing Baron or something,
and then you just fuckin'
lose the game thanks to that.
And that feels horrible.
That feels awful.
- That doesn't feel great.
But then, you know, you can
leave that game be like,
"All right, I could
have set that up better.
"I could have done things better
"to make that W more secured."
- I don't look at games that deep, man.
I just do it to fuckin' escape.
- Well, no, I don't look at it deep.
What happens is that I enjoy games,
and then I look into now,
when we're talking about it,
I'm thinking, "Okay, why do
I enjoy the games that way?"
And that's why I'm talking
about it now, Joey.
I'm not sitting there at my window sill.
Like, "Why do I enjoy suffering in League?
"I don't know."
- And that is the question
that we're posing.
Why do you enjoy suffering in League?
- That is the question to
all League players right now.
- I'm League free, man.
I haven't played the game in-
- I'm League free.
(everyone laughs)
- I haven't played a ranked game of League
in like two months, man.
Three months.
- I went to League anonymous,
and I just fuckin' said it, man.
I was like, "Yeah, I'm League free."
Congratulations, everybody claps.
- Basically I enjoy league the most
when I don't care about winning or losing.
Like, that's literally my enjoyment
of those types of competitive games.
- I think Joey's just
a little gamer bitch.
A little crybaby boy.
And that's where we're
going to end it today.
(Connor laughs)
- I'm sorry I enjoy winning at games.
- I'm sorry I just enjoy the-
- I'm gonna so be one of
those old people like,
"These kids these days they
don't know how to lose.
"They need to learn how to lose it all."
- "How do they expect to win at life
"if they can't even win at a video game?"
(everyone laughs)
- That's what I'm sayin', man.
How can you expect to win at life, Garnt,
when you can't even take a loss
in fuckin' Smash Bros, Joey?
- I don't know, man.
I'm winning so far.
- Wait until that loss comes along, Joey.
You won't be able to
suffer as a human being.
You better work.
- Oh no, I apologize that I'm giving off
a very normal human fuckin' experience.
- People take enough Ls in life.
Life throws enough at fuckin' people
that some people would just
want an escape from that,
you know what I mean?
- Some people just want an escape!
- Agree to disagree.
- What do you think comment section?
- Why did you have to say that?
Now, we have to hear it.
Now this is gonna be a
shit show in the comments.
- What do you think comments section?
- Are you a Chad gamer or
a little baby boy Joey?
- Which philosophy do
you fuckin' side with?
- What I like about philosophy,
there's no correct answer.
- Except my answer.
- Do you want to be the
Navy Seals dad like Connor
who just can't stand his
son losing at anything?
- Or do you want to be a normal father?
Let us know in the comments.
- You just want to be
a normal loving father.
(everyone laughs)
- Who loves their
children for who they are.
Let us know.
- I gave up on most of the sports I did.
(everyone laughs)
Anyway, thank you to these lovely patrons
on screen right now.
- Look at them.
- They are just so beautiful.
- Look at these beautiful people.
This guy does ranked sex that's for sure.
(everyone laughs)
- But hey, if you'd like
to join us on the Patreon,
make sure to go to Patreon.com/TrashTaste.
Also follow us on Twitter, subreddit,
and if you're an audio only listener
then follow us on Spotify,
all that good stuff.
- All right, I've been Chad gamer boy.
- I'm very tired.
- Bye, bye.
This has been an episode of Trash Taste.
That's a thing.
(chill music plays)